[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
yo yo
might check mic check what's going on
people lords of the realm what's going
on
hustling motivate what's going on
brother patcha lord pubg what's going on
let me know if my level is good arcade
what's going on cyrus you know i mean
saying fox
and uh what's going on what's up hustle
that's what's up
arcade what's up what's up akw what's
going on
cyrus burke stop listening to my hot mic
i could have been saying disparaging
things don't be recording that
[Music]
you're addict talk to the people right
quick just make sure your levels
alex in the is y'all he worked like 18
hours
really in the bushes king should be
arriving shortly we're going to get neal
up in here man
talk some gaming thank you facts and
cracking much appreciate lunken locker
what's going on at six layer
thank you brother six later thank you
again for the the tv knowledge baby
oh you like the face back yeah the
master clean so the wolves is out babe
you see the wolves
you see the wheels with mexicans wait
for it yeah
yeah don't go to your local store with
those those bass though i won't get
y'all locked up
but yeah the best is clean man go
support that we got that pinned up on
the top you know i'm saying we'll be
shopping people out if they do purchases
on a live stream
red raven what's going on k asante
salute what's up brother thank you for
the love earlier much appreciated
so well yeah king of ba here so i'm
gonna use this because you know the
copyright strike with his damn music
when he come in with music
and um addicts he's here he's in the
bushes he worked 18 hours so i'll be
pulling up and i'm gonna go get neal
now so i'm gonna see y'all in a bit
[Music]
oh and bounty boy what's up i see you
see player i'd shout you out
you already know
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
hi this is lord sovereign from the iron
lord podcast
as you guys may recall a few months back
king david otw announced an amazing
giveaway for the xbox series x
well i'm proud to announce that the iron
lords podcast will once again be giving
away another console
at the end of this year and that console
will be a playstation
5. you heard correctly so
how do you get in on this amazing
giveaway let me explain
if you're already a member of the round
of the realm what are you waiting for
head on over to patreon.com go to the
ironlord's podcast patreon page
become a member of the realm to get your
chance to win a playstation 5.
you can also join us on youtube
ironlordpodcast
become a member of the realm and you
will also have a ballot to win
a playstation 5 console and if you want
to support us on both platforms
you'll have two ballots for each system
to win either a playstation 5 console or
of course as king david said
and xbox series x this is an amazing
opportunity
that the iron lord podcasts are so happy
to bring to our community because you
guys give so much back to us
so again if you're not a member of the
realm yet what are you waiting for
go out join the realm of either patreon
or youtube and until next time i'll see
you at the round table
hopefully we're live but before we start
the show we look like we have some
technical stream difficulties
so chat talk to me let me know boom
[Music]
[Music]
you you might check my check let me know
if y'all can hear me talk to me real
quick
levels is good all right cool neil oh
talk to the people real quick just might
check
yeah yes sir yes sir solve by check
hello hello hello here we go king my
check
all right so hopefully we can start now
we go straight to entry y'all had enough
song
[Laughter]
look we're just jumping right in man we
jump right in yo
let me know what's good because i'm not
talking until it's still good while the
stream is live
with the video now all right my checks
good video is good
all right so far so good how that stream
looking solved how that stream look okay
on the youtube refresh
it is all right it's all right you know
you know it's gonna start you know
fading out yeah it says stop talking but
we rolling with it
that's right everybody got thumbs up my
fingers
and we are finally live
welcome to the iron lords podcast and
now
also live on lords of gaming.net so
check that out
episode number 181 and it's another
glorious sunday we're back at the round
table on the lord's day
and today we are very excited about our
special guest
and we've got aerial nights never yield
playstation 5 in the hands of media ps5
dynamic cooling
and xbox worldwide launch to discuss so
we're going to get right into it
i want to introduce a lord who stylized
3d artistry as a game developer
is truly on the rise after revealing his
latest title at gamescom
2020. knowledge is this futurized style
detroit runner equipped with the most
banging beats
but also represents a beacon of hope for
devs of color to aspire for greatness
and never yield within our games
industry
introducing the independent developer
and creator of the aerial knights never
yield franchise
the real life professor of 3d art
and the lord who rides with no more
heroes as his
best game of all time live from detroit
and making his debut into the realm of
the lords
my man lord neal jones how you doing sir
yo i just want to say you got the most
hood movie boys
development development honor to have
you in the realm so we gotta show you
the proper respect man what's going on
sir how you been man
i'm cool i'm cool i appreciate it uh i
appreciate the intro it's like
way fancier than i'm used to
most most people would just be like yo
we got this black dab over here
they'd be like it's him it's him
with a dark one at oh my god
other than game development man have you
ever had a chance to play anything
recently in the games
on your on your radar uh i played a
little bit of uh ghost destruction i was
trying to
play that update uh like um
you know i was on the fence about it
because at first when i saw the game
i was like you know it looks really
standard you know assassin's creed type
thing but man that game is
dope yeah and then
legends is crazy i just hit 100.
like that rank 100 not rank 100 but you
know um
power yes whatever yeah yes
getting ready ready yeah man it's a cool
mode i gotta jump in there man
everyone's telling me good things and
it's just cool to see like a free title
update you know
multi-player support for a single-player
game so i thought that was pretty cool
man so that's been pretty much
expected yeah i have to agree half
degree so pretty much that's been it's
been uh ghost just working on uh aerial
nights there sir
yeah i ain't really got too much time
other than uh because it's not just
aerial nights i've been working with
a couple games i worked on uh jet for a
little bit okay um
that's coming out on the ps5 uh so y'all
should you know follow their twitter
okay okay what's the name of that joint
plug that what's that jack
jack they told it at the um psx
whenever they launched the ps5 they did
a trailer for it no no
i only did art for or helped do the art
for it very
minimal but like day games that the game
is really interesting
so somebody keep me keeping you busy man
and of course we have well we had
the four horsemen of gaming but uh what
if the wolves one of the lords is down
man so shout out to attic man he's not
not doing well brother had worked 19
hours double shift
he came in so don't blame at it don't
throw him in the bushes don't throw him
in the bushes
you know say it's all me [ __ ] i mean i
made a judgment call we got to protect
the wolves you know what i'm saying but
we still got
the three other horsemen gaming here in
the realm and of course we got our most
technical gaming lord the solo gamer who
lives for the single player selfish
experience
and also the softstradamus the lord of
clarity
and lord patreon of the ironbank my man
lord sovereign how we doing
you know what i'll do i'm creeping feed
the wolves
baby boogie down baby you know how we do
it
when this gotta go here the dick's going
down
you're not catching me sleeping make
sure y'all get that hotness man
teespring.com
i see it pinned up in there the wolves
is out the gators let's go
there's too many cameras out here
yeah okay we got night music with the
four dollar super chat good morning to
you
as well sir then we have squirrely dan
with the five dollar super chat come on
guys this is not we start a podcast on
my birthday how we started i got a joke
let's get this cracking also started
from missing the last two casts live on
vacate with the fam not at all brother
enjoy that big
then we have kurt with the five dollar
super shot y'all got me reaching for my
wallet with all these masks
there's a stick up we don't see them
super chat it's gonna be a problem we
got perfect
shogun with the five dollar super chat
good morning welcome lord neal
kyle gave us a preview of his new single
chat talk to me oh yeah
yeah listen to the bars
lord suave steal your girl and your
wallet
i'm not looking swab today i'm looking
at an addict today i didn't even get a
chance of shaving
you guys let me get this oh you got him
you got him
vendetta with the 20 super chat thank
you sir lord king i know you throw all
souls like games in the bushes but i
like to offer you a challenge
if you can get through one play one
playthrough of demon souls for ps5
i'll gift you the next video game of
your choice okay so you
heard that kick um i'm not buying that
game
you can save your money and don't gift
it to me
oh let me get stitched with the
five-hour super chat is there anything
else we can make cake do
we'll stitch on guarding them yeah you
see where i'm at with it right
wait till my intros go i'm taking tired
of you i'm gonna find where you at and
and we coming for you yo evan squirrelly
every smelly got it out to you what's up
man who's been going to anything else
you've been playing
anything going on with you no man
i've been in the bushes like the past
month man they really
nothing not even hades i can't literally
i don't have time to pull out my switch
and play a little bit so
that's what it's been man so just now
you know how i do when the
when the new consoles come in the house
i got to start you know i got to clean
the house top to bottom you know the
baby
you know babies are coming in so you
know yeah
you don't want to affect the babies with
the old baby business
so that is sir looks like we got the
list you want to get the liz
uh the liz with the three dollar super
chat cigar bourbon mowing the long and
aisle piece
let's go absolutely
yeah man i'm done that is in the bushes
no doubt no doubt
and of course we have the incredible
hulk of this aka
the access gamer oh the prophet
of xbox king of the statues demands
nothing less than that premium
experience
it is the leader of the fraud alert
movement
beloved lord king how we doing sir oh
you know how we doing the gators
feed the wolves the wolves is out or
they will feed off of you
i know what it is when i walk down the
street i'm wearing this it's a movement
dudes be like what
excuse me excuse me
wait wait wait till they see that tm
right next to it
all right so um a couple of things i
want to get out of the way let's get to
it
oh oh oh oh oh will me hood
oh the crappy challenge
i ain't never scared you ain't never
scared y'all
right now so i'm gonna let all you dudes
know if you're not a member of the realm
or
patreon member you will never see me die
yeah we the realm voted man they want us
they what king did the problems the
challenge what chip challenge
i start sweating when i see you i swear
yeah i got a comfortable
it is what it is it's diva in there make
sure demo ain't in the chat y'all know
how he broke
let me on devo got nowhere to go
let me let me talk about something real
quick let's get it
that little man talk oh man okay
so i saw something like i was asleep the
other day and
you know i go on twitter and i saw my
name in something
i'm like why is somebody at me all right
so
all that derogatory talk calling
somebody at xbot
and ponies um i'm i'm your
best ex bot when you when you say
ignorant stuff like that that's like
calling me your best n-word
when i call somebody a pony
i'm not never i don't ever attach
anyone's name to it
never because those are fighting words
right right those are fighting words
because literally you're being
disrespectful
so that's my best n word right
kids move if if he didn't take offense
to it
that's him right i know the ashen one
took offense to it
right and i took offense to it okay
now if you're a content creator you
don't want no smoke with me
don't act me and nothing i feel that i
don't add anybody
in anything i post and i leave it there
notice i didn't at you when i went at
you
right right so if you're a friend
and you don't know what you said
was out of the line right
you should have reevaluated all your
little likes that you got see because
like i put there before seems to me like
you trying to catch a wave by adding my
name to something
the ocean don't need to catch a wave i
make the wave
i feel you bro so what we're gonna do is
you're gonna refrain from doing that
divisive talk
and separating individuals from this
side to that side
because there's no sides these are the
invisible gamers bro we all gamers y'all
all right we don't sit in these board
rooms we're not privy to these
conversations with these companies
so we're going to stop that towing that
line stop that
now you can rep your box you like your
box whatever
but don't be disrespectful to other
individuals for whatever they like or
whatever they choose
right leave them in that space but rep
your stuff
right and leave my name out of it
because the smoke is terrible
i feel you now what i was doing this
weekend before wait before you i just
need to add over here
and we'll move on from man talk um i
just got to say deals laughing
i just got to say like i feel where
you're coming from all i would say is
this y'all again like king said
wrap your side that's cool you got a
favorite we all got preferences that's
cool
the problem i'm seeing which are online
is too much of the personal attacks
when you start personalizing it you know
what i'm saying and you ask somebody
or you're doing you making fun of
somebody or they mental illness or
you're putting pictures up or something
of that
like that's we gamers we we we from that
and like king said
the lords are different the lord's moved
different we are not with the disrespect
so everybody come in we're all gamers
that's the unifying common bond here
you know what i'm saying that's what it
should be about that's all i wanted to
say on that but other than that
you know what i'm saying get your joint
off king no i'm saying what you've been
playing oh okay whoa
my my man her beat the greater
ufc fighter khabib is on his joint yo he
put your man in the rolling death cradle
shout out to tekken
throw him in a rolling death cradle yo
he put him in a rolling death crib as
soon as he put him in a rolling death
cradle he attacked
his feet you know like soon as he put it
in there he was like nah
the man was asleep though you better
sleep he's he's
never been in that move like you know
the panic set into a dude
when he locked i've never seen the move
i only see him in attacking that's when
you did it to me
so i was tapping two i was tapping for
the dude
the way he had his body contorted and
moved into a little ball he had him in a
ball
and his face like from from round one
his face the level of determination i'm
trying to kill you yeah
with everything i get you with and if i
get you you know
it's you know what he evolved into but i
love this guy so much
i love him so much remember i thought he
could jump into the crowds i love it
i love this guy so much for the simple
fact he's evolved his style from
not just the floor right his stand-up
game
yeah it's bonkers yeah yeah
i saw when he when he jabbed when he
jabbed the con in the in the mouth i was
like
that was a respect yeah that was a
respect yeah that was that was
uh i'ma tell you man uh khabib to me
my favorite fighter of all time is hicks
and gracie
nixon gracie never graced uh the uh the
ufc because he wanted
more money than they were willing to
give him and he deserved that money um
this is a man that's never been defeated
this is a man who takes
no one for granted he fights everyone
and like like kim was saying when you go
in there and you see the determination
on his face
this is a dude that once that door
closes in the octagon
his job is to kill you his job is to
kill you
and it's the referee's job to stop him
from killing you
it is it is very much that because i i
remember seeing an interview with hicks
and gracie and he said the same things
like
i go in there with the willingness to
die right
yeah and and and i expect the person my
opponent to have that same willingness
so
so they know where where i'm coming from
when i attack them
right and it is not my place and then
the thing is as soon as the match is
over
you are my brother i am worried about
you
everything yes and he said i love you
before
during and after but that that moment
during yeah
i'm trying to kill you even if i love
you it is what it is trading with bears
at a young age
and that's khabib like it could be
listen all you have to say is the man
trained with bears
he has no equal in in that regard and
it doesn't matter who he's in there
against it doesn't matter the style
it doesn't matter he i've never doubted
this man
being able to put anyone away um
and and it just show you know because
gage is a beast
i don't even watch ufc but i heard it
like
i heard the escape the face and i i
opened up twitter and saw it
you know like damn you woke me up
and popping something everybody really
yeah yeah but you know i catch the uh i
catch the highlights and stuff and
you know i used a kickbox back in the
day so like i
after after you do it it's like you
respect it it's not even respected
it's like you don't uh you you either
choose
like you either like this i'm all in
yeah okay
i gotta make a decision about all that
about that about this life
you're great you'll say you
like yeah you get kicked in the face
that one good time yeah i am yeah
i'm good i'm good that's when you still
re-evaluate your life
like i literally i was really good at it
i got kicked in the face
real hard like a real kid cause i was i
was rocking with people
in my tear yeah and it was like all
right let's move you up
um and then this is one dude um he was
smaller than me too he was like
i had a good foot on him when they were
confident he kicked me in the face
match wasn't even over i just walked off
i started packing up my stuff
salute the deal you really understand
the levels to this
the funny thing is stuff like that like
sometimes it's like y'all i'm done right
and then sometimes it's even like
your your body it knows it ain't that
you're that you're different
and you don't even realize it because i
remember you know
like yo i used to i used to play
baseball i was i was very good at that
you used to wrestle
yeah in baseball i took
a i took a a a fastball
oh right between my eyes like right
between mine
like yo the seams the seams were right
here yo
and then so you know i i was good i
healed i came back
you know i practiced i got back when i
got back into game situations
no matter what i did when i got a ball
smoked at me yeah
like i just jumped why am i doing this
i'm good i'm fine
and it was just my it was my mind and my
body reacting in a way that i couldn't
control anymore
and i was never the same never the same
sometimes you never it's a good point
like some experiences i gotta hit time
on this side yeah
uh game pass right now katana zero is
inside gameplay
i cannot recommend that game more yes
all right um that's the only game right
now that has uh tore me away from um
neon abyss
right uh slightly though slightly a
little bit
but this kantana zero is not a roguelike
it's it's an action game yeah it's fire
with a rewind feature
it's one hit def yeah right so you could
be all the way through the board
and that one dude get that one hit on
you boop you're dead
right and you got to start it all over
it is probably one of the
best new action games i got my hands on
right now
and there's different ways to attack it
it's like mass effects with the skill
tree
i mean with the um with the dialogue
tree the dialogue tree directly affects
what's going to happen
next right so it's not something that
you have to wait a couple of uh
board for something like that if you
choose the wrong thing at the wrong time
you're into a different situation that's
what i really like the game about
because it changes
on the fly for whatever your response is
to certain
situations and stimuli so you can attack
it in a stealth manner you can attack it
many different ways on how you do a
board it's no
one set way and you can do you can use
the environment
to uh mask your attacks it is something
that if you have game pass
give it a check out check it out there's
a couple other games that came in there
right now but
if you guys see it trust me yeah and
there's a lot of blood so watch out for
the kids
no doubt i got to hit you with the time
sir
it's a long show what's up do we got the
army super chats yeah yeah we have uh
eagles fans 76 to 20
yo the storefront won't load need that
iop merch
um that's weird check it out we got you
right now bro we
we're gonna keep getting super cheap
i'll put it in the middle yeah okay then
we got uh smitty smith for the two
dollars
kabeem yeah yeah yeah he will be missed
uh he's not coming back for myself yeah
he's definitely not coming back
he's one of those dudes when he says it
is over that's it yeah you believe it
you believe it yeah make sure you get
these uh
there goes the store fronts in there now
put it in there on the block
real quick before we get the blockers up
before we get into uh
to neil's intro guys next sunday
is d-day ladies and gentlemen next
sunday we will announce the winners
of the xbox series x sweepstakes and the
ps5
suites sweepstakes so if you have not
joined the realm either on patreon
on youtube be sure you're in there make
sure you're in there because they're cut
off
the cut off if it's not there in the
list
by saturday evening yeah it encounters
so
it's a wrap so please if you plan to
join the realm
do it soon all right well let me get
that homie vagabondo please say
something brother thank you for the
final final canadian supreme i spot
watch my destiny bro so yeah
you do that slow-mo said solve did you
get my bribe anyway
we have the gary ninja himself the
shinobi unlocked lord cognito time
damn spreading down
it's in the front of the eye you're
gonna be dirty yeah we cold blooding out
here we cold blooded in the room they'll
tell you what you want to hear what you
need to hear i'll make it quick man make
sure y'all catch that last word with eat
boxes we had the destiny
fam up in the building wilhelm scream
teaser teddy these are the clan mates
the fun the jokes
all that man was a good show please
check that out it's been a lot of
destiny you know what i'm saying um
that's pretty much it but do a little
catch up but i haven't got a chance to
play too much
oh wow we got two shout outs i want to
hit up a game over
brian salute 5 super chat brother king i
respect what you said and i'm repping my
65
htcl game standing tall so he right
that's right you
you in your playstation day one right no
need to go up don't worry about it yeah
good salute put the horns in there for
our brother
makai 28 welcome to the realm brother
we got you man put it up in there man so
look long show a lot to talk about so um
now that we got to what the lord's been
playing and all the man talking the good
stuff
at ufc i want to stop the kick in the
face hey
i want to start with lord neal his video
game system history
his journey into game development and of
course what led him to creating the
promising
and stylized runner aerial knights
neville yields so
lord neil let's start from the very
beginning what was some of the first
video game systems you had and what got
you into gaming
um oh i mean we can make this real quick
because it's not a long history
i have nothing like nothing nothing wow
uh
my grandma who's like detroit og she
like
like a bunch of restaurants in detroit
like dealt with like
you know all the motown people like i
didn't even believe her at first she
would tell stories about oh i dealt with
this person i didn't know who these
people were
you know smokey mom said that who's
smokey
he's getting curious joking but like
just like this and then aretha franklin
died
and i was like oh like they gave us
tickets to go to her funeral or whatever
she's like i ain't going to hurt you
oh i was like what's wrong with rutha
franklin she was like and then she told
me the story of what aretha franklin did
to her i was like is that
i ain't believe her and then i have to
clean up her basement
um and i just found pictures and notes
and all these things from these famous
people
wow and i was like all that stuff was
true
wow [ __ ] my grandma has smoked
right she could write a book brother
the only reason i say that is because my
grandma she plays like a giant role
in like all of this um anyway she uh
you know she took me and my brother's in
she raised this all by herself
um we was loud and annoying so she uh
she bought us a
sega genesis we had the worst games yeah
yeah we had the um what was it
uh the lion king oh shout out to those
bad numbers
that kind of makes sense because your
animation is legit
so you had the best animation games back
unless y'all want to give me some more
money for this
that's right it yeah we had genesis and
then
uh she bought us a nintendo 64
with only pokemon stadium wow um
that's the only game we ever had for
that
and then um i saved up my money and we
got a um
a gamecube star fox and and smashers
okay smash brothers and uh animal
crossing that's
about it that's what's up and then you
know and then i i became old enough to
save up for my own
stuff and it was like it was like
nintendo then i switched over to 360.
okay at the end of 360 i ended up
playing you know destiny
absolute salute that's so funny yeah
yeah you would say
from the 64 on that it was more your
personal involvement you were kind of
trying to get systems to save us against
systems on your own
yeah i had a choice then shout out to
grandma you know what she did
she instilled that hustle in you she
gave you the whack stuff that you didn't
want to make you
make sure that you got a job to buy what
you wanted she didn't know she brought
anything that had disney or
power rangers on it all right but here's
the thing there's a culture back in the
day i want to know if you was a part of
like
were you in the trading games culture
like well friends
come over and stuff like that because
that's how we used to survive when you
know the moms and them was acting up
we wouldn't you know we would we would
actually get together okay so what you
getting you gonna get this one i'm gonna
get this
so we can have stuff to trade amongst
each other and borrow from each other
like did you guys do that with
your friends i did it once and then i
didn't get my game back
oh hell no you're here from detroit
yeah friendship over
he said all right so um let me get back
my lion king what lion king
oh man come on they keep my boy deal
dirty it was like
one game
it was a really hard bad game and i was
like i don't care
but then my grandma thought that i
didn't get it back at you like you
traded your game somewhere
yeah yeah i like your grandma man i like
i see the journey still going through
doing the games doing the trade and all
that stuff
now i want to get into obviously um as
far as your journey and saying okay
game development right and like what
made you say okay
i want to pursue this career now to make
games and then the other thing a lot of
people don't realize is that you are
actually a professor of 3d art so i want
to
talk about both of those things so let's
start first one with game development
and what inspired you okay um when i was
in high school i went to um
you know robotics you know we just went
to ford foundations and all this
these places out here and uh did some
like robotics and that's basically where
they just teach you how to you know the
mechanical
stuff about you know building robots and
stuff together it was really cool
um i didn't have a clue of what i wanted
to do but i play video games all the
time so like
dumb me i was just like you know what
i'm gonna make video games
that was a bit like in ninth grade and i
just like there was no backup plan i was
just like this is what i'm gonna do and
if not i guess i'm working at mcdonald's
for us
[Laughter]
yeah like i got real lucky that i
happened to be okay
at you know getting stuff done with it
uh but a lot of people like they just
try to fall into it and like
you know with no kind of plan like i did
but it doesn't really
you know work out all the time yeah no i
hate you man i mean because so
so basically like what was the first
journey like what was the first would
you say like step that really puts you
on your way
as far as game development what would
you what do you think was the first like
kind of monumental step
um i play uh you know i i i went to a
for-profit school it's terrible school
i'm not gonna promote them but you know
like that whole thing i thought i was
going to be a coder and stuff and i
tried a bunch of stuff and i was trash
and everything
and then i bro i hated coding that
coding broke me
because i remember with some little bs
database stuff
just to do something simple and i was
like oh no this is terrible
i got so much respect for y'all that
could do any of that
because like that to me is when i knew
that i was not about that life
i love getting away you know what give
me dirty
so and it gives you all the the the
tools but
you just got to put it together yup i
couldn't put it together i couldn't make
a leg just to get the guy in the stance
it would take like two hours for me to
do this and i'm like yeah
game i went back to the store like five
minutes after i purchased that's when i
know
gamestop was really raping dudes
so i went inside gamestop and i was like
yo um this game is defective
it ain't right i got my money back right
they gave me
exactly what the store credit was for i
paid like 60 dollars
they gave me 23. yeah that's the jerking
back in the day right
did y'all do the game stop hustle where
you would be the game a used game within
six days and take it back yes
sir yes so we'll do all the loopholes
continue
that's all i did because i had no money
absolutely i felt bad after a while but
then like i got older and i was like
it's a corporation whatever
i don't hurt nobody nobody no no
so yeah so you would say like what like
what was the breakthrough that you was
like okay
i'm getting more confident i can do this
yeah yeah uh i think like a lot of
people when they were kids they you know
messed around with neopets
uh and you know they had that html thing
and like you know that really like eased
me into like oh this is how this stuff
is done oh i can do this
i couldn't do that um i found out later
but um i fell into like doing 3d art i
got like semi good at that and just
you know kept hustling with that um
found some like little internships and
like
you know pretty much free work um but i
could build a resume off of
nice um i ended up after you know
graduating and getting the degree or
whatever
um you know floated around a bunch of
places just doing like real
like contract work don't nobody actually
hire nobody you know right that's real
talking about
things i did the same thing contract
work to get the resume up right get the
experience so they're showing
that you're proving that you've in this
work environment you can do this yep so
i i did that for a while
um then i you know uh worked on some
like games that never
got released um then i worked on some
indie games like some
some more free work and then i really
got frustrated because like after like
almost 10 years
of like you know doing contract work and
putting the work in uh
game industry still wouldn't give me
like any kind of like play
like i got thousands of emails that i
sent out was like yo am i good enough
and then like nah
there's something about you that don't
really fit in so we
like they had no reason for not hiring
me they'd just be like yeah you don't
really fit our you know studio culture
and then i was like you know all right
all right so um
you know it like this game was actually
going to be my last game um i was like
i'm gonna do this you know put my money
into it put my time into it
if it don't work out i'm just gonna you
know move on and you know do some day
job stuff and like
you know really get my life together but
you know
people seem to like it i'm gonna hold
you there because we go
i got a whole segment for you with
aerial day i don't want you to get
but what i want to do is first of all
salute you
on your perseverance right not giving up
still keeping pushing forward
still doing the work again contract work
getting the experience
building that resume right even when
you're getting these adversities of not
necessarily people
you know wanting to bring you into the
team but again i also
didn't want to forget which i think is
really remarkable that you do again you
being a professor of 3d art that is
really cool because you are now teaching
people
part of your craft can you give us a
little bit of background about that
yeah once i moved back from uh i was
living in texas for a little bit for
like some job i came back
um and one of my boys who like i helped
out you know you know you just do favors
and forget for people sometimes
um he hit me up because he you know he
started running this game program at
this local college
he was like yo no one else in michigan
can like
you know do this stuff like like you
know kind of like you can
i was he was like ask me come in just
like teach one class
you know they you know they was feeling
me but i always been real with it i was
like you know
i was like yo like game industry won't
hire me
but you know i i think i'm pretty okay
at what what i
would do right so uh you know they was
feeling it uh
it worked out i've been teaching there
for almost four years now that's what's
up right like was it any different like
i i admire you because like i don't know
king song like could you just walk into
a class and like
professor it is is real to me man i'm
gonna be honest like
this experience of being on a podcast it
it just
it's one of those things where my my
fear of being in front of a crowd is
lessened considerably right which is
weird because we're not in front of
anybody
right but my my fear of sort of getting
getting up and speaking doesn't it 76
thanks for purchasing that neck gate i
see you brother the wolves was out feed
the wolves i see you
yeah for me it's diminished considerably
like i don't i
you know that beforehand you know i'd be
i'd be probably in a corner somewhere
just puking up or something like that
but
nah i so i think it's just just
practicing
doing that sort of stuff in whatever
sort of realm it is whether it's
actually in front of a classroom or just
just people in general yeah well you
know when you know people
uh what you can call it uh are listening
to you and just
i don't know i got over it afterwards
yeah i don't you know i don't have no
problems yeah i can talk in front of
millions of people
yeah i know we don't you you got no
problem
i'm prepared for what god said he told
me
at some point in time i'm gonna get what
he said he's gonna give me you're gonna
get those
off yeah i want everything else rick's
off real quick let's catch up on the
super chats real quick and then uh
eagles fan is out here he's got
[Laughter]
[Music]
the lords are not responsible we are
promoting health
fitness in the gym we want these in the
gym we want to promote social media
it's a new gang in the street called the
irony
[Laughter]
super chat yo king rise and shine took
me off of neon abyss
yo i purchased rise and sign um i think
it's getting ready to leave game pass
right now so if y'all want to get it on
the discount go try it out real quick
before it leaves
i purchased that game no doubt and we
have gerald mack with the five dollar
super chat
shout out to the iop and guest neil
jones big up black devs iop
on podcast thank you thank you brother
thank you and then
put the crest in the chat for our newest
member jose
f thank you sir welcome today are you
trying to get that xbox to that
playstation here we go
how you doing i'm trying to get the xbox
to play slate
what you gotta do is just hit that join
button
button
that's a super uh side note though but
it's amazing how so many like uh
influencers get like consoles before the
devs
like i know so many devs who like could
not get one
i've been on calls with like some higher
ups
and i was like yo can you so can you
slap me at x
and everyone always says that's not my
department oh
man
but we all caught up yeah well all right
cool so look man
i want to again i don't i wanted to say
very night because uh we got to get to
it
so um let's just get into this main
event of why we are
here you know say and uh what what's the
what's the rick
what's the rick rule joy hit the music
[Music]
and i'm on the right track
[Music]
[Applause]
knocking though you know what i'm saying
yeah don't say no switch love look man
he gotta go for the big
platform yeah we know switch gonna come
in we working on this what's gonna come
in hard
i can't announce nothing but i'm
definitely it's rough
okay okay you don't say yo salute man so
look man lord dale
you know what led you to creating this
this
this promising you know stylized runner
look like it's in futuristic detroit
anime vibes
you know so i want you to educate the
realm about ariel knights
never you oh thanks man um yeah
thanks for i'm looking at the chat uh i
appreciate y'all y'all y'all very kind
um but yeah uh like when i said
you know come up with something i was
going to make as like my last game
uh it's not my last game now
um but yeah when i was coming up with
something to make i wanted to make
something that was like a little bit
familiar
um but that i had a lot of room to uh
change
because people can look at this game and
just think that it's like one of those
standard runners
but it's not that at all once you play
it it feels totally different and
you know i switch it up with like a lot
of like heavily black influenced music
and like i literally like took or well
my idea was to take you know
the culture and like put it into it and
i don't want to generalize black people
but like my personal
view of ours and like put into it um
because you know some like i know a lot
of black people are gonna be like yeah i
don't really rock with this but
you know hey more power to you um i'm
just like doing something that
references i don't
really know nobody's gonna see that
trailer and not rock with that
like yo i'm telling you right now
you know i really appreciate it because
i don't like i don't do a lot of video
editing and then like just like
my second trailer i ever cut together um
so like
i was like real nervous when i was
making it i was sweating i was like i
don't know
let me tell you right now you made me a
fan because you said it best we're going
to deep deep dive with the music in a
minute but
for me you know and again speaking again
black culture
hip-hop you know the lord's come from
that you know what i'm saying and
i always feel it's a it's a genre that's
not represented a lot
so i think it's funny solve how you can
watch something a trailer of the same
thing
two different times but if the music is
appealing to you
yeah it has a different connection right
like
i'm like i don't care what's going on
i'm in
you know what i'm saying so it's one of
those things but the thing too i want to
get back to the game we'll get we're
going to
do a deep dive with the music but i want
to thank like what you did
talk about what you did as far as
detroit reffing because i saw some
references bro
now now give me if i'm off now okay all
right what i caught you had
the ed your guy right i'm assuming it's
you the aerial knight really said
but if not it's cool but what i was
gonna say i love the detroit joyce i
i caught some beverly hills cop vibes
from detroit
i was like that's grandma or somebody in
the house know about eddie murphy ever
very very hills cops because
it felt like the jacket the whole thing
yes you know about his shirt though
nah talk to me so in beverly hills cop
well that's how the story goes
like eddie murphy came to detroit and
there's this school that i went to
called mufford like the high school
he went in there he went to the school
to walk around or whatever um they gave
him the
like the uh the shirt that they wear in
gym and
he was like oh yeah i'm gonna wear this
in the movie he wore the whole movie
yeah
on on his shirt and i was like man
that's the dopest story
that's fire brother well i had no idea
baby go back and watch that
that's what's up salute man
i was just saying he's dope that's
what's up and all the things one random
question i gotta ask when we get into
music
what's the deal with that neo boy joy
what's that any significance of that in
the game that handheld
nah neo just means new yeah i kind of
call it game boy so
right okay okay that's what's up brother
this was my question that little game
inside looks like it's legit can you
play that game too
yeah it's a minigame oh yeah
that's actually been my gamer tag since
i was like 10.
that's great to me it the moment i saw
that
it put a smile on my face because it's
like this is a guy making the game by
himself
and he's making sure you know his name
fax you're not being timid about it
yeah and then hearing your story about
how you know basically
the the the industry at large has kind
of not given allowed you to
to kind of make your your place in it
and you say i'ma make my own place
and you know when you see it like a
kojima game kojima make sure you know
it's his game
and that's literally why i did it
exactly
i was like yes yes you would know my
name
i literally got one of my points because
i was gonna ask them i was like it's
such a rare thing
you know what i'm saying as an indie
developer just a developer in general
like you said to put that name it's
aerial nights
never you you know saying this is the
brand area so i i think that prefix
is so important you know what i'm saying
to have ownership right
it it creates a brand you know what i'm
saying i think that's really cool
for you to do that you know at the start
of your not last game because you won't
be yeah yeah
that's right yeah
i wasn't throwing everything out there i
was just like yo i i don't care no more
i'm just going to do like put my name on
it put my face everywhere
if they don't like it then oh well
nothing to lose that's right everything
in the game
i feel yes i respect that let's get
these super chat solver that i've got
some more questions for them we have uh
smitty smith with the five dollar super
chat cnn
they've been a string of series x's and
ps5's gone missing
six the lords made me do it hey
trouble
[Laughter]
ronin 357 with the 5 trailer made me a
day one
purchaser go beat salute through aerial
night
brother appreciation then we have web
head 420 with the 5
chat shout out to the guest i love
seeing black developers in the industry
keep up the good
work absolutely absolutely then we have
black ronin again with the five dollar
super chat we need more black devs slash
studios to allow us to show the world
how we want to be seen and portrayed
we all caught up uh no we have hold on
we got a couple added here we have k
asante with the template salute to the
lord so excited you guys have been
showcasing neil in his game
i've been hyped since i saw this at that
xbox showcase keep going neal don't quit
we got you out here supporting us
[Music]
salute to the admin lord hyde bought a
netgate i see the net gators getting
cops right now
i see them i don't know what they plan
to do with them
but thank you it's a movie get out there
and do what you got to do god bless you
then we have gerald mack with the five
dollar super chat day one purchase
thank you black men we out here
absolutely yes so
the crest in the chat for the newest
member atrocity
nice salute thank you for joining around
brother really thank you
really means a lot man so yeah like
that'll be caught up right we call the
raps off
yeah so we got to get to it down here
like yeah yeah
one thing like i said that you really
focus on is dope is that music the beats
the amazing trailer you don't see i want
to shout out your homie on what is it
correct my pronunciation wrong danime
sama
yeah that's his online tag with that new
name
but like hip-hop jazz inspired
now we getting that all through the game
and also
who's spitting the bars on that trailer
track i gotta know about that oh okay uh
so
uh the rapper is austin hey um
i don't know where did i do from i met
him online uh i went through like a lot
of like artists
um and no one really fit and then like
he was like my last like
i was like here if you want to try to do
something and he sent me
like he sent me back that exact track in
an hour with no feedback
that was like this man you crazy three
words
he's spitting right
[Music]
so again we got we got your homie now as
far as dan
he's doing the music for the game like
is it going to be all hip-hop and jazz
tracks throughout the each stage of the
runner like how are we doing
yeah it's it's a uh think of like if you
started imagining uh a cowboy bebop
movie
okay would that sound what that would
sound like and dan
just created that he added uh some like
other elements of like you know uh
eight-bit games for the you know the the
the uh handheld portions and then we
have this like
the last level would be the most amazing
most happiest thing you
ever play because like um
like we have the lyrics going matching
oh movements of the game
and like everything man it's like oh
good i can't wait
for people to play that last level in
that music because
it like it literally turns into an
orchestra yeah
and and it's crazy we wrapped up the
soundtrack this week
and like uh yeah i think like people
even though like i love what i did i
love
ann did yeah i can't wait for people
like to really hear this music and
yeah you definitely don't have a bundle
of soundtrack oh i was just about to say
you don't put the soundtrack with this
fam
edition because i know most of the time
right now i'm buying digital
right so um you're going to have a
physical copy as well
that you're going to be selling if
somebody hits me up
shout out to head up game shut up games
what's up right now but you know they uh
you know heads up really cool they
working on everything uh
you know but we don't definitely get the
uh digital stuff out there you know with
all the stuff going on it's really hard
to do anything physically right now yeah
i know i feel that i feel yeah so be it
at you sometimes i forget sorry yeah
i want it just as much as you do so two
things
before i get you installed you know
again for someone who's not
who's new to the genre of a runner
explain to them like what that is they
don't know what that is you know what
i'm saying
okay yeah yeah so um like i don't know
if you play temple run or anything like
that but basically it's
uh where the camera is in the set
position um and as
obstacles come at you you have to like
do the preset movements
to get through those obstacles um and
wait and the way that i
like kind of flipped that on his head is
like once you run into those obstacles
the camera actually moves with you
you have choices more choices than one
as to how to
get through an obstacle you always well
you almost always have
uh like options gotcha do you want to
jump over something or do you want to
slide under it well you know you have to
choose one
gosh um so that's kind of how i take it
and flip it mm-hmm
fair enough fair enough so have you had
some questions before you switch i said
i got another question
no are you uh specifically no no no uh
well the thing is
decide the sidescrolling vibes right i
mean obviously it's not mirrors
because mirza is just first person but
besides uh i know you said no more
heroes
was was a big inspiration for you in
terms of your favorite games what other
games sort of inspired this because i
look at this and i
obviously i do see temple run from a
different perspective i see mirror's
edge
i even see a little bit and this is a
recent game but if you played my friend
pedro
that's sort of like that that sort of
kinetic movement how everything
you know pushes you towards one
direction and then you use sort of that
movement in order to do different sort
of moves off of the actual environment
so i was wondering exactly what it is
that inspired you to
make this particular type of game yeah
that's a that's a really good question
my friend pedro actually
scared me when i first started
it's funny to hear developers say that
right like these are the real
conversations they must have before
release of their old title that they've
been working on
it's real tough yeah because you don't
know what no one else is working on
um like i've been working on this uh for
it's about to be two years uh my friend
pedro came out like last year
um and as soon as like as soon as people
started like
posting about it i was like oh god
and i was like is that is that a whole
year worth of work in the trash
oh man yeah
it's it's definitely pressure to like
that's why you want to be so different
that you know you're not worried about
that right and that's that's the risk of
you know making something
or taking like a genre and like kind of
making it your own
other people are probably doing the same
thing absolutely
no that's dope man oh but he i'm sorry i
don't even ask
i took an inspiration from uh like a few
games like cannonball
and like uh the examples that you stated
but i mixed it with like you know
spider-verse with movement and you know
all types of stuff uh
it was really random stuff actually like
no more heroes lollipop chainsaw
more of the feeling of those games not
the actual content because you know you
play those games and you can tell that
the person who made it
really didn't care right right oh if you
like it you like it if you don't you
don't and that's kind of where i go
i'm with it where i don't need everybody
to love the game i feel like
i'm making it for a few people there you
go
yeah you got to have you got to have
that suit of mentality this is my game
this is for me
i want this is this is what i want to
put out into the world mm-hmm yup
yeah like you said this is it and when
you got to the point of
every time you said that you hit you
didn't notice that
like you said okay well i don't know
who's gonna be the rapper man i'm gonna
get this dude with a shot this is it
and then he he sent it back in an hour
he was like wow right
so it's every time you add to this is it
it's really this is it
like this is it so yo i'm i i
know like when i saw it like you see
it's something discerning in your eye
you know a banger when you see it like
you know a good car when you see it
you know a beautiful woman when you see
her oh you you know
something that stands out when you see
it yeah
i saw this but then i also heard it yeah
so first i'm looking at it visually my
eyes is like boy
right but then the music is like
i'm like oh
because he hit me and i guess he was
getting upset with us
because yeah because i'm like no we got
our private chat and i'm like yo did you
watch the trailer because nobody hit me
back cause i've been there like
you know you know because i know king
ain't watching yet so
i know i ain't watching it yeah because
i would hit him back right he knows this
he knows me
right so he hit me privately
like yo okay enough with your bs i know
you see
me see you see this now see this
i clicked it and i saw it on my phone
and said oh
yeah right yo so i i couldn't see it on
my phone no more i got
to see it because i got an 80 inch
screen
there's certain games that i mean
everything i honestly for us
we've been ever since the start i guess
the original xbox right where surround
sound really
became a big deal is when you really
like music has always been big to us in
games but when you start hearing that
how the music is is sort of integrated
in in a lot of ways the actual rhythm of
the gameplay
right uh when when you have that
integration like you said wait to get to
the final level of the game where that
music is bumping and you're moving
and i'm sure you're upgraded and you and
your movements are crazy and the parkour
is crazy
it's the thing where it's like a flow
you're in you get into this flow state
where everything about the game works
it's the gameplay the music
the vibe everything about it works and i
feel like that
this is that type of game right where it
is you're going to be on on on your
console like bumping yeah
i was just about to say that because
it's like it could be elaine
right because again a runner and if
you're doing a runner
and you've got good music in conjunction
with the stylish art style and i love
the anime takes like i'm really
i'm really feeling that you know what
i'm saying i just it's just a good vibe
it's a good combination so
we're pulling for you brother man and
you know this the reason why i asked for
for the music if you're going to do a
little special little bundle
you saw how i come into the show when
i'm getting my warm my pre-workout you
you already know
i'm coming into music so when i'm
whipping down the street
i want somebody like yo what's that my
dude i'm like y'all that's that ain't
real nice my god
i wouldn't be able to say this because i
definitely pull up with a soundtrack
like i'm a vanilla ice it's just crazy
i'll make sure y'all y'all taken care of
oh i appreciate your brother i
appreciate you brother
let's get these super chats and i got a
couple more questions sure give me a
moment we got a lot
i know we had a lot of things they asked
and they they hype they hype
uh we have uh pixel budgie with the five
dollar super chat respect for putting us
on
to this dev and his joint uh we'll
support it the beats
put the crust in the chat for the newest
member of the realm no
ducks given and thank you for the
language sir thank you
beautiful and we got our brother 108
dragons
super chat that salute to my homies ilp
and crack crab and lobster it's a great
sunday day one purchase for me
yeah brooklyn in the house what's that
one away salute that's my god
we gotta rep detroit right now detroit
we gotta wrap up you know what's in it
yeah no one else does
lion's
[Music]
neal they will make room for me
real night there you go sounds like a
good teacher
he created books he allows us to use
that
yeah he's creative in the realm then we
have
uh entering the realm lord
that'd be crazy if he really is supposed
to work
right there we have
stitch with the two dollar super chat
game pass maybe
hey phil boy boy i'm gonna tell you
where you're talking about that
oh something may be in development
don't worry he ain't breaking nda xbox
he we out here
yeah y'all better make sure that he put
his name on that dotted line
what else we got and we got clutch man
with the two dollar super chat this
feels like a hip hop mirror's edge
good analogy good analogy then we have
stream kingdom with the two dollars
which have the music gives me an nba
streets volume
two vibes i don't even think of that
that is good
yeah shout out to smitty smith files
which have mario in the back like yo
king did you see that aerial nights
y'all
he's holding on to the wall he stood up
on his own did we get married
welcome to the realm sir i see a lot of
people want them xboxes on that
playstation i can see what's going on
here y'all see the diaz is getting
uh shorter and stuff is being canceled
joel's like i need to get someplace
you don't want that email all right oh
yeah
email that squirrelly day with the day
one for the north
salute you already know he said this
joint is fire
yeah we like what we see it too man we
definitely like what we're feeling so
look we all caught up
but uh yeah man so again i want to also
even though he was supposed to make it
but i want to shout out um
head up games you know what i'm saying
because um shout out gregory those guys
you know how did that connection happen
as far as being a publisher
for um you know i'm saying every year uh
uh i you know i've been making trailers
for this game like trying to get
somebody to pay attention to it
um i made the trailer before this one we
just showed
uh and you know they caught one of it uh
them and a couple other uh people hit me
up all at once
um and you know uh they they sent a real
strong email where they just like broke
down exactly what i was trying to do
with
my goals like before i even said
anything to them
like before they even made an offer i
kind of like was like
they understand so like that's what i'm
rocking with
that's because to me like money you know
i i just need enough to you know make
the next game
i don't really care about you know i'm
not a corporation like that i just need
enough to get by
enough for you so the money was like
wasn't really a concern
the more of the concern was like who i'm
working with who i'm trying to make
connections with because you know you
you especially you know
being black you gotta be around the
right people absolutely you know you're
taking advantage of
absolutely absolutely and i want to
highlight
what i consider the magic moment which
is again
debuting your trailer you know gamescom
2020 you know what i'm saying like
what's that feeling like
when you know to see that trailer go out
and then to see the response and then
people hitting you up
right to say yo what's up
like give me how that how does that feel
as a game developer
i don't know i would sleep when
it was like a long stretch for like week
before then because they
was like oh we need a trailer you got to
cut this together like that trailer i
could i told you
i it was my third one i was sweating i
did it in like an hour and a half
or whatever and just sent it out and
didn't even think about it and
and you know gamescom happened i was
napping on my couch
i woke up you know i saw the
notifications you know i said my thank
yous but then i you know went back to
working on the game
[Music]
he said what my game is gonna be sold
it is a real cool thing to see man and
the final question i have to ask
obviously i talk about it you mentioned
it a few times
you know again being a developer of
color you know in an industry where
let's be honest it's not a lot of
hashtag black game dev
so my thing is like you brought up some
of the challenges personally
that you had but like what other advice
would you give
to aspiring developers of color who want
to get in the industry
you know and may see a game like never
yield where the character looks like
them
they see a developer where developer
looks like them you know and in this
spot like what advice can you give to
that
new generation coming in you know trying
to get into the games industry
absolutely not i i am like winging this
uh everything i i do is random uh and if
i don't even know if i didn't
necessarily recreate it
because like i said this is going to be
my last game this is like i give up
type of thing so i would would just tell
them just just do you you should
like anybody coming in now should have a
way easier time
than me and like everybody i know who's
been doing this for a while
uh just because you know like the entry
point
is better people are more open and
understanding of you know different
cultures working with each other and uh
trying to work remotely
like that but when i was like coming in
like 10 years ago it wasn't having none
of that they was like you need to move
to l.a tomorrow
[Music]
yeah and we still will say no to your
face
like not even your face in in the uh
email
right yeah so it's it was
much rougher but um now i think you know
we're working on it it's definitely not
where it needs to be but
you know um you know one step at a time
and and then you know we all have enough
tools to make games ourselves it just
takes a really long time to you know
right uh get good i don't like saying
that but you know that's real
that's true that's real no i respect it
man i mean at the end of the day like i
said
i love your perseverance i love you like
look i'm doing what i want to do
i don't care this is the last shot i'm
doing it how i want to do it
and cause you've made games before there
was there was a couple of other drinks
that you you've
actually you know you've created before
and um i thought that was really dope
you know with this this whole
the way the approach you take almost
like the i don't care
approach this last one and if they don't
like it whatever you know what i'm
saying
like this is how i'm rocking it and it's
it's really it's kind of like holes
yeah yeah leaving facts
people forgot pre-writing it was
different like
he kept trying he wasn't getting no love
was it getting old you know like
he was he was like this is it this is
this is the last joint
yeah and when he did that that's what he
just took off to a different space
it was in a different place you know
sobs
and uh car can tell you i ain't the
whole fan yeah
but when he got to the point where you
know that's it
you know this is the this is the last
right right
if you ain't feeling me then stop
telling me to make old stuff
if you ain't feeling me then this is my
last joint and whatever
his last work was was his best work
because he got he was free for those
chains yeah like
that's what the game looked like it
looked like freedom like first of all
i'm not running jumping over no tables
so
and i'm seeing that i'm like well that's
something i can't do and i'm gonna have
fun doing it
again i mean is that is that where the
title comes from the never yield
is it that really it was originally
named ashes to ashes because i was about
to be way darker with
it oh yeah he uh taken like the ashes of
his murdered family
and like doing something like you're
going oh right
right no that's where originally was
from but uh then like
uh you know people really like the
aspect of you know dying and you know
getting another shot to try it then you
know um
i heard i actually heard a song or
something they was like i'm never gonna
yield or something like that
i was like that's a good thing
i see the gregor meister in the chat you
were supposed to be in here man what's
going on brother salute to gregory chad
we see you brother
that's what's up man so i'll get these
super chats right quick and then we'll
wrap up this segment
sure we have a gaming forte with the
five dollar super chat
uh what's up lords only us detroiters
understand the pain these detroit lions
put us through that's why i jumped
shipped 20 years ago
i ain't never been on the ship oh yo you
know you don't claim the lions bro
i don't claim no football team but if i
did it definitely wouldn't be the line
barry sanders
barry sanders the greatest player in
tech mobile ever
yo shout out to delilah hd with the 15
super chat shout out to the realm
as a fan of runners i can't wait to play
it fire emoji fire emoji
yeah she's definitely out here shout out
get slow let's get slow
we got slow-mo back slap with the 5
super chat thanks for putting us on to
this dev and his game
definitely on my promising upcoming
games radar fantastic
that's what's up uh before before we
switch uh to the next update because i
definitely want to talk about how i'm
i'm not legit iron lord oh my my destiny
before before we get like all that i i
do want to say
like i really appreciate you all because
like online can be really toxic and
like especially like you know being of
color
i think we definitely all need to
support each other um so like
me personally as a developer i've been
trying to find ways that i can support
you know black media and stuff like that
so part like not to get into the details
of my
contract or anything like that but part
of like uh my contract when i was
talking to like publishers and stuff
like that i was like it is a requirement
that you put a priority on uh black
media yeah like
i'm not saying that you can we can only
talk to black media i'm saying they get
priorities
i'm only going to talk to the black
musician
you're stupid
shout out to gregory who was apologizing
he had daylight saving times he you know
he's probably should shout out to dead
games head up games
you know that was brought to my
attention i wasn't going to mention i'm
glad you mentioned it
because neil that was brought to my
attention and i said man
that is so cool you don't say it because
at the end of the day he's like look
i get it you know this is my game we got
to promote it
but i also want to make sure you guys
are cognizant
that a black media outlet or a back
podcast or website
you know has it and when that when
gregor hit me up
to say yo check this out he specifically
said that and and shout out to greg
cause he's like yo
iron is one of the most positive
movements i know you guys i feel would
be perfect
so from the heart gregor like that's
love neal
that's love you know what i'm saying and
we got like you said we got to stick
together we got to support each other
all this tearing each other down
personal tax you see king shut that down
in the beginning of the podcast
you know what i'm saying it's about
supporting each other because at the end
of the day we all love video games man
this is what it's about is that
excitement for a game
it's the cool new genre you're creating
you know what i'm saying we got
musical representation for the first
time that i'm very happy about
and an art style that i love so we go
and support man and like i said salute
to you
for making that specific distinction and
again can't give you enough kudos
brother that that is so dope i
appreciate it so dope bro
but um let's get before we get to super
chats um we got got convention we got
that joint
we got all pixel bit and then we went we
gotta ask we're gonna do the top five
stuff but uh soft catch up real quick
we got smitty smith super spot super fat
super chat
yes yo yo matt respect for neil he is
just keeping it
a buck yes then we got pixel
g with the two dollar super chat uh
cough bo jackson cough tecmo yes bo
jackson is the actual goat
in technical facts but i didn't run with
him i ran with barry sanders
i was with i was with bo jackson i was
actually
jeff don't like me for that lord ha
definitely don't like it
no shout out to greg he said that's
saved by evening y'all you already know
salut you know i had the rap man
we caught up bro yes sir all right cool
so let's ask the question we asked all
the guests in the round
lord neil you're on the hot seat now you
know what i'm saying so i need
i think i know one of them but i need
those top five
video games or franchises of
all time for lord now oh that's easy
oh okay let's get it um if you don't got
one guy over here uh we're gonna
we're gonna have an issue i already know
that game is there no no
i don't even know that game's gonna be
in there wow it's on your twitter sir
let's go let's go i thought i thought
you meant destiny
uh yeah yeah no more heroes uh people
always ask me about no more heroes and i
say
because if you play that game he doesn't
care like
he clearly did not care what nobody
thought
and it was amazing yeah there's
no other game where you play it and you
can feel than like not
giving that you know
but yeah no more heroes uh i would say
uh inside
oh okay all right
uh last of us oh yes
which one which one which one the one a
one you know like anything like part two
i like part two but part two was one of
those types of games
like it was it was like um one of those
movies where after you watch it once
you're good like fruitful i'm never
gonna watch that movie again
i feel you yeah it's some stuff in there
that i can't go back to
yeah yeah yeah because it wasn't my
story it was her story
yeah no that's that's what threw me off
and but you know it was it's definitely
doped okay um but number three would
probably be uh
did i say three we got no yeah no more
heroes
no more heroes inside inside uh last of
us
um the dlc for black fat flag um
yeah yeah yeah that was dope yes
and then like my number five always
switches up depending on what i'm
playing
probably just like i would probably just
say some random sony exclusive
uh but you know i probably put like a
smash brothers there that's how i'm
feeling today that's how you're feeling
right now okay
okay you're a smash ultimate
oh you're no no no no no no no no no no
no no no no no no the gamecube smash oh
okay
all right that's a big contention right
so i didn't know it's like
beef like dude dudes don't like that
don't eat
me leo versus ultimate it's like yeah
i hear it's like a real thing it's
memories you know yeah
yeah absolutely absolutely but i
actually made a
a a list on my twitter a while ago it
was like the uh the top 25 games that
all like
black gamers should play whatever and
it's not even just like games with black
people in them this is like you know
ready to rumble stuff like that oh
that was ready to roll when you start to
whip
on something shout out to the dreamcast
that was that thing i played that game
so much when it first came out you know
and it made me make sure that i wanted
to get a dream cast was beside sonic
but that was definitely i think the
first or the second game that i put in
as soon as i got my dreamcast
yeah you're just games like like even
though they're not made by black people
black people definitely need to play
them games
crazy taxi crazy
kid though not a dream cats brother no i
i know i was jealous that i didn't
so we got that we got the five it's
amazing five shout out to gregor giving
out his five
grand tourism battle field journey what
remains of edith
and limbo slash inside all right
crackers
listen
actually
[Laughter]
and the final question favorite console
of
all time past or present oh
probably ps4
i mean like you can't argue with like
just technology like it just kills you
with overwhelming
technology where you're like it's the
first console you can just straight up
download
everything um you know the chat online
it gave it fixed destiny for me yeah i'm
gonna play destiny on 360. oh lord
um yeah it was just like it's everybody
had one
yeah or has one whatever yeah no listen
what they it's a tremendous generation
for sony so we can't even
dude this is tremendous five tremendous
lists man
chad is loving you obviously you are
more than welcome to hang out i know
we're a long-form podcast we're not
kidding yeah but if you got if you think
you gotta die
sunday i ain't gonna know oh you rock it
sunday okay
let's go let's go so um look man what we
got to do is get this
poll results in last week's pro results
under people have spoken to the question
with the ps5 ui now reveal
what feature has you most excited about
the interface the winner of the four-way
ilp
poll at 52 percent was the messi
lawrence once again i don't care
this system is getting delayed until i
see digital foundry with the hands on
the castle
launch coming in at second place
at 33 of the vote was ssd loading speeds
and clean
interface coming in at third place at
nine percent with
4k hdr superior dashboard
and at last place at four percent of the
vote was ps5 snap feature with tips and
friendless
group shout out to all the lords who
participate in the poll lord king
your messy lords xbox lords are
hijacking
these polls what are your thoughts sir
my team rules that's what i say
but yo shout out to john lennon yo john
i feel
your pain right now with the fact that
you gotta review
trailers you gotta look at trailers and
you gotta go through trailers and
and figure out what they're doing
because they don't want to tell the
truth for shane it doesn't
slide you uh a development kit system
they don't want to send you what's going
on because they don't want the world to
know the truth
they don't want the world
i understand exactly what's going on
john because they know what happened
last time
when you had the truth over there so
don't worry uh
even if you got to purchase your joint i
want you back on the show
so we can go into what you have
discovered sir yeah we'll get we'll get
we'll get john and digital foundry back
on then around but until then
um yeah i'll be up first uh ps5
wait hold on let me get me get a few
things for you please please take care
we gotta get one away dragons real quick
with the five dollar super chat you know
my brother stay
your course believe in yourself and live
your dream i will support you my brother
i'm sold because of your focus
i'm in all day absolutely and then
real quick again so i i just got a dm
from one of our brethren in the realm
lord uh
keezy will 26 indicating and this
is for all of you people in the realm
patreon and youtube who
were just signed up today have been
signed up to win these consoles
our friend lord kizzy will 26 is going
to donate two months of
game pass so actually this one for the
xbox two month
game pass to the winner of the xbox
series x
okay all right absolutely wait don't you
get too much
for free anyway maybe oh
let me find out you know something that
we don't know
oh i know nothing stop breaking nda's
continue
you'll stop that right now
some extra incentive for our
members of the realm two extra months of
game pass for the winner of the xbox
series x
so shout out to lord uh keysworld26 aka
akw on youtube
he's in the chat so if you hit him you
see him no doubt
all right so we all caught up together
yes sir all right so
be that we transitioned for the poll and
listen shout out to the fighter i'm
going by my house
oh we've got the playstation we going to
oh my god yo you messy man
have now been spotted in the wild major
media outlets so
shout out to the book of jt gotta salute
the whole team lawrenceofgaming.net
you know saying with the tremendous
article right now putting it out there
so it looks like yeah a lot of media
outlets are getting them shout out to i
believe are
jeff i can't believe bakalar
with the picture in the order oh who out
here buying merch somebody
oh shout out to sean zulu i see that
long team premium sleeve i see you
brother got the phil dominance one i see
you i see you
um so yeah so yeah jeff baccala he got
that and
we got austin evans you know what i'm
saying we're starting to see a lot more
media outlets you know having it
oh lord wait a second yes yes sir
they posted a controller no they posted
a box with the system sir that is oh
okay okay
austin correct austin evans had a
picture of the
of course all right let me talk about
that other box that was in the corner
okay
uh not people but you know media outlets
and stuff getting it early
i don't think they should i don't think
anybody should get it early
but we're about to get to you right now
lord nils hold on one second
so look it's it's been hit this week you
know a lot of people start a lot of
media outlets
are getting them you know so i want to
bring this to the round table to the
revlon neil let's sit
set you off right now you got some
strong feelings about it you know how
are you feeling because
the the i guess because kids here i have
to say
the uh feeling was that because media
outlets were not
getting the um console like the series x
that there's a potential for the system
to be delayed
so with that information do you think
the delay rumors are now dead
or you know do you feel it's still
coming on schedule and how did you feel
about media people get it
well um i think uh it's definitely
coming out on time because
um they wouldn't uh uh
they wouldn't have they would have
pushed the date back by now if it wasn't
coming out
right um not like two two or three weeks
left
yeah yeah it's definitely coming out um
but uh media outlets
uh i i get it from uh for games because
you know day one they want people to
you know see those reviews right uh but
for specifically consoles
i never understood it especially with
you know after the ps4
everything's sold out so what's the
purpose of seeing a review
early for a console that you can't buy
um
so you don't want you don't want the you
don't want the little heads up on on the
ui
you don't want no technical comparisons
you know
i mean maybe some people do i i don't
watch that kind of stuff
you've been making a game
even as a gamer i'm like uh i mean
that's cool but like
it kind of like uh shows a little
elitism of of the you know of the big
you know media companies right yeah we
got it you know
right you don't yeah yeah let me let me
flip it on you know what about
um two other let's say sorry you started
giving them to other youtube content
creators would you be okay i'm saying
nobody no oh sorry so wait you want
nobody so wait what's your reasoning
behind
no one should get it fairness
because it like honestly it's the only
way to be fair because if nobody gets it
then it's completely fair
um you know if you pre-ordered it you
get it if you didn't pre-order it you
don't get it
um even with media outlets
like um like there's always going to be
bias there's always philosophy like
okay um uh some media outlets that get
preference like
i don't want to put no names out there
in trouble
i'll do that don't worry about that
the kid got you back don't worry about
it uh another place only gets like
two right okay you know you know you're
playing favorites like
no matter how you uh flipping i feel
what you're going now your whole thing
is
is okay i got you i got y'all i just
said perspective a little better now
lloyd suff what do you feel sir the uh
ps5 is in the wow
it's delayed it's official now is what
are we doing well
it better not be because whoever has
whoever has those uh those uh
preview units is going to get getting
knocks on their door you know
people wearing people wearing this right
dude
[Laughter]
i mean i'm glad i'm glad they're out
there
um it's funny because i've never i've
never heard neil's
take on it and it's i mean because
you're so used to
you're so used to seeing you know look
the press is gonna get it early the
other ones are gonna tell us about how
this stuff works is that any other
um but it it's it's interesting to hear
neil's point because
especially in a world now where the
playing field in terms of
coverage is it's been somewhat
evened out just because the power of the
youtuber
and the power of the actual uh you know
games journalists
is kind of that that's a little lopsided
now right like the
the influencer and the gaming youtuber
um in a lot of ways
has a lot more clout than than with the
general public
right and then the actual uh the
journalists so it's it's
it's an interesting take um i i'd like
to have somebody tell me
kind of how stuff works although i at
the end of the day once i get into my
house
i'm going to make my own decisions right
um but you like to have an idea and for
us it's good because there's oh this
there's smoke to be had
right there's talking points
that's all i'm here for
i'm glad they have it let's see what it
is um you know i it's kind of funny to
me that digital foundry doesn't have it
but
i guess uh they indicated that nobody in
europe had them yet either
so yeah and but that's the thing again
going back to neil's point like tom
warren has it
uh well well actually the point was the
verge has it
right it's not it wasn't specifically it
didn't specifically indicate tom warren
you know whatever the case may be um i'm
just glad that it's out there they're
going to talk about it
digital finally eventually get it and
break it down you know when other when
other outlets get it you know
when you know when greg miller gets it
yeah it's kind of funny when that
happens it's like okay
yeah i you were gonna get it like you
know whatever it's the uh
it's a rich mentality where
like just because you have so many
followers you get more because
you've got early access to somebody
who's just starting off and who wants to
build that
but they're they're you know set up for
failure yeah
i was listening to i forgot oh man i
forgot the podcast it was but they had a
guest on
who was specifically talking about the
fact that you know with the xbox series
x it's like okay it went out in waves
right
and the first way they specifically
mentioned the first wave went out to
certain people right and and this person
specifically pointed out i was like why
isn't go
getting into the the hands of of of
minority content creators why is why are
they left
why are they not in that first wave why
is this how things are done right
um and then some people did get it but
it was like okay that
we need to change how this how this
happens so that everybody gets it
right up front right if you're gonna
give it to give it out give it out to
everybody in one shot
don't do it in waves um because again
once the scoop is had the scoop is had
you know what that means that's a good
point
yeah you may gravitate i mean you're
obviously going to gravitate to whom
whomever you like and whoever you want
the coverage from
but if you like if it's a brand new
console first people to have it
and be able to talk about it if you're
excited for the console you're going to
want to see that coverage no matter what
right so it's it's not fair in that
regard it's absolutely not fair enough
so these are some valid boys you guys
are opening my eyes to some things i
definitely
hear where you're coming from let's get
to super chat we get king
uh what did i miss here yeah all right
so okay we got the white little gamer
right we got the white little gamer with
the five dollar super chat
i'm gonna donate shadow complex and afro
samurai 2 to the winner
yes 5. oh snap that's right you can't
play it never mind
yo and i love afro samurai oh stop
i'm getting curious i really do uh that
is one of the best animation movies with
music
oh the rhythm is crazy yeah
then we have vincent brazile with the 20
super chat love you guys podcast
never get to catch you live just wanted
to show myself
oh thank you brother delilah she really
agrees with neil um
you know as far as have you know not
having people get those you know
consoles she said it kills the unpack
and on on an open experience yeah no i
definitely where you're coming from
definitely opening my eyes so lord
king you have been one of the proponents
of this system being delayed
i'm still standing in that squad oh you
still you're still riding with this
i'm still i'm still trying to believe it
there you go deal is learning
how i'm going to say it all right um
it's not going to be in it as an
abundance
how they would want it to be i don't i
don't
think they have the stock
so it's going to be a launch for launch
sake
okay like the save face type of thing
like i showed up at the party
mm-hmm right you know i'm here i was i
was here even though that's what we're
doing
okay this is only still for 15 minutes
this is what we're doing
yeah this is what we're doing just like
this like this
you know all those pre-orders being
canceled and all that stuff that's going
down and people trying to figure out
am i safe literally looking at their
emails every day did sony not choose me
like am i not worthy to hold this
you know you're not worthy no so you
know and i think you know
there's gonna be a lot of people that
got it but as far as it reaching
people's hands
right didn't see that all i saw was a
box um all i saw was this damn
controller again
this controller is out here son and it's
been passing around like a hacky sack
i'm gonna tell you right now i'm pretty
sure that dudes have got controllers all
over and my man that work in game style
yeah i was like yo the controllers is in
i said the controllers is in everybody's
house nobody care about the controllers
have you seen the systems yet
and he told me no it ain't no sisters in
the store he said but we got our xboxes
i said i feel you i understand that the
truth so i know when i code it it's
pretty good
but again i think they're going to
launch for launch sake say they launched
for launch day and then
later on it's going to be in abundance
it's going to show up in abundance
uh some somewhere around like december
like probably like december 12th or
something like that so you're saying
it's gonna launch yes yeah yeah no no no
no no no no exactly exactly get them
don't be afraid of that i believe
it's it's going to launch
for launch's sake to say it okay
you understand which means it's logical
it's going to be in such
short supply that you might as well not
even showed up like
it was like you going to a barbecue and
they only got three wings oh my god my
man
like i came here to eat my man why is
only three wins here and
three wings is just sitting there and
they're telling you this is elitist
let me let me fix your analogy though
it's like somebody called you and
invited you to a barbecue
and said hey we ain't got a plate for
you but you can come anyway
and you went anyway
exactly they telling you before the
barbecue
yo you we ain't got no rule for you
all these people anybody who got the
rsvp
y'all could eat y'all good but um you
know
it's good okay so after seeing the ui
and after hearing that is in
in people's hands i'm like okay good
fantastic this is what we wanted to see
in fact
i know that they're trying to control
the narrative as much as possible the
only way you do that is when
you're in a position of weakness and
you're not trying to show your weakness
until actual launch look at that
like what did i do now you know what
we're dealing with
exactly so all right you know what it is
they are not the most powerful console
right so who cares
no no i actually i do so i mean because
it's just the talking point for smoke
you know it's about to smoke okay
i'm about smoke all right so because we
care they cared
when they had the power right when that
xbox was 900p
and he was walking around where 1080p
remember resolution gate not today it's
over
so we're back this is what happens when
you kick sand in my face
we're back so now
i'm crazy patty i don't care you know
how when you said that this is my last
game i don't care i'm i'm crazy petty
hey hey
so all right so we're at this point
right now where
and this is where the profit of xbox
comes in right
we're at this point right now xbox
nation and this is what i'm talking
about nation
we're at this point right now where
we're taking anything that we could use
against them in the coming wars
but i do honestly believe though
that they're going to release uh as uh
in low quantities and then ramp it up as
much as possible we'll try to get it to
those outlets
once they get that pipe stream in they
can just keep funding them
in as they get them made you know so uh
i think there was problems with the
yield and stuff and i think all that
stuff was true
i really do because yeah with a smoke
there's definitely fire
oh it's a playstation oh god
[Music]
but at the same time i do believe that
it was stuff going on that hampered them
at some point at some point
and they they're going to get to the
point where they want to release that
does it work for them i don't care um
but i do
like the fact that people are getting
them and they can review them because
it starts to turn into an even playing
field instead of hearing
all this xbox news where everybody has
one there and everybody houses
and people with thanks i got four
playstations on pre-order
i'm pretty scared for three of them
i'm pretty terrified for three of them
all right so but
one yeah four what happened to them
releasing their limited quantity
not quite meal
[Laughter]
this definitely kills the narrative that
this system is going to be delayed
i believe that it is here i mean to
kick's point he may
be onto something as far as limited
stock or quantity i'll give him that
he may be on something with that but i
feel like honestly it's it's coming out
when the me you know the major media
guys
have it you know i to me it's just about
transparency that's all i care you know
it exists it's coming you know i i
personally
like not that i need anot a media
influencer
to justify my purchase but there are
some people's
opinion i respect like digital foundry i
respect
their technical prowess when it comes to
stuff so
when it comes to ui or when it comes to
any type of graphical fidelity things
if they got their hands i look for that
stuff but to neil's point i do hear what
he's saying
in reference to uh even playing field a
fair playing field and the rich getting
richer so to speak
because at the end of the day it would
be cool
to have influencers who it's not just
something to me
yeah it's fine if they get it to you
yeah you gotta get it you know what um
because almost xbox supporter so sony if
you really want
me to turn to your side maybe sending
demon souls and that because i'm never
buying demon souls
i'm just going to play things in my way
and maybe i can give you a good review
okay thank you sir for your you know
digital foundry like should if we gonna
give it to anybody
they should be the only ones to get it
because they're like ireland yes like
for everybody where no one has an issue
with them
all they do is be like hey here's the
stats yeah this is it here's the numbers
this is we're just telling you what it
is and like i said that kind of stuff i
really appreciate it but yeah like i
said i'm just happy
that finally we're getting close to
launch soon this stuff's going to be
over
you know but yeah i definitely hear what
you're saying and the sad part about it
like you said neil is that
unfortunately it's a numbers game it's a
reach game
it's a popularity game you know and a
lot of times the decisions that are made
is based on a person's influence in
reach so they give it to these specific
members
you ain't travis scott all right so yeah
there it is that's cool
what are you trying to do you got a hot
album out i guess so there it is that's
all you know it is what it is you don't
know drake
uh we got eagles fan 76 with the five
dollar super chat well what with the
hate for df
they were great when they trashed the
xbox one but since xbox proved their
engineering to digital foundry with the
1x and xbox series x they're they're
biased
um yeah that's an interesting one
because uh the past week
i've seen a lot of just and we've seen
this a lot right when
when when when the console ponies or the
all the bots are out there and they
don't like what digital foundry says
about their specific piece of plastic
all of a sudden they're biased and
that's always going to continue to be
the case even if
like neil said they're ireland which
they are um
what i didn't like seeing this week in
the past couple of weeks in particular
is uh the responses that people are
having to
to things that are being said by
particularly john yeah i don't like
what's going on with you
i don't like what's going on like you
guys obviously see that
john is a person who is so passionate
about what he does
he takes it very seriously and because
he's on social media he cares what the
fans think
right and you know when you see that a
person is being affected by
by absolute negativity if you're that
person who continues
to sort of flame fan that fire
um it's just it's disgusting to me it's
disgusting to me shout out to everybody
who came out in john's defense to sort
of and to let him know you know what
you need to walk away from it yeah you
need to walk away from it because
the the fact of the matter is that it's
social media
it's unfortunate but you can't get past
it without just
ignoring it it is the way it is it's
super unfortunate
but guys like this is ridiculous when
these are the guys that tell you how it
is flat out
no bias they tell you what's what how it
works
and they're going to tell you which one
works better right right and and you you
may be
salty about what they say the fact of
the matter is man both of these machines
are going to be out there both these
museums are going to do great things
just leave it at that but yeah the art
school stuff
on that personal attack hitting
attacking people with mental issues and
all that over
a console that's whack to me bro it's
just whack like it you look like a
cornball
there's nothing respectful about it i i
can't co-sign that you know what i'm
saying and at the end of the day just
because the resolution didn't go your
way
or the the ray tracing wasn't you know
up to what you thought it was going to
be versus something else and all that
stuff let's stop man at the end of the
day this is video games it's gaming
we're supposed to be unified for it it's
really disgusting once you take it
personal
you're already on some other lane that
nobody's respecting so
that that's the end of that but let's
get let's get this super chat there
and we have our bounty boom with the 10
super chat i agree with you i disagree
because
what if everybody getting their system
and something is wrong with it
and we're already paid and we're not
going to get it yeah i feel that
either way yeah no but i feel it i mean
warranty i mean look launch consoles is
you know that that's you you're jumping
into the crazy territory
where's my fire extinguisher
let me get deuteronomy right quick
because i see he said john continues to
participate in the effort
he gets no love no first of all you're
jumping on someone's jumping on his
timeline
to be disrespectful and personal that's
different and about no love for no
console it ain't that serious
so if you in that mindset where it's
that serious when you gotta attack
somebody
personally that's on you you know and at
the same time these are public
figures you don't realize it's like a
celebrity do you no matter how much
twit tweets and stuff people get just or
share volume alone based on their
stature
that's unlike a regular inbox or a
regular social media profile
you know i'm saying it's a public figure
so that's where it's different again
out of your feelings with that that
cannot support that i'm sorry he's a
real
cool dude like he's the best dude and
i'm not listen here's the thing i don't
even want to say because oh he was old
he was on launch shows so yeah
i don't care who it is i don't care if
anybody doing a service
that we are looking for information on
we're clicking
their channel you're on his timeline so
if you don't like it get off his
timeline
right that's it's just as simple as that
he's telling you that it's hurtful to
him
yeah he's like yo it's bothering me he's
being more honest than a lot of people
are he's saying listen guys
this is messing me up because i care so
much
that i can't even pull myself away
because hey this is my job hey
this is probably if there's ever a time
where i have
that i have more work than i ever have
because
of a console cycle right like dude
you can't i'm sorry sorry i can't i
can't jack that like i can't co-sign
any person
this is plastic i look crazy literally
plastic i mean and you know it shows
weakness on your
part if you can only support one
ecosystem and
you know get better it's like yo why
wouldn't you doing this why would i go
to a youtube channel or someone i don't
like right
listen i did not like when every time i
went there xbox was 900 people
yeah we had to do that right i had to
eat that bagel
and it was disgusting so of course it's
right
sometimes you're going to hear something
that is hurtful to you i guess
but here's the right thing even if you
disagree or you feel that that person is
biased
why are you showing up every week you
know why they're showing up they're
showing up because some people like to
hurt
exactly there's something wrong with you
you keep going to watch something that
you don't like like it's crazy i love
their breakdowns i love when he do retro
stuff
i love the i love anybody that does
stuff with passion
okay not not bad stuff but you know um
you know good stuff
and when he does his retro stuff with
passion that man is so
in tune with what he's doing like we we
we talked about certain things
uh about um what was that the the
the super graphics only me and him
oh yeah can have a conversation about a
piece of technology
that he's seen twice that he got his
hands on
the guy really cares if you're bothering
him online
stop right what type of keyboard warrior
you what what type of
uh of uh weird
feeling that you're getting out of
demeaning somebody online
for doing their job it's kind of
disgusting and i didn't see it because i
don't be
on into that toxic stuff i try to stay
away from that stuff but
now would you when y'all said it i went
on the timeline and i looked at it i was
like this is
really messed up yeah you know it's
terrible it's crazy
anyways enough of that let's go ahead
and get that off um
yeah we got jonathan b with the five
dollar super chat i heard they set those
psi
those ps5s out so they can dynamically
tune the fan
that's gonna come with equalizer
settings oh my god
it's a free heater
is coming moving along there we have sin
vendetta with the five dollar super jack
king
if it takes someone gifting you demon
souls in order for you to play it hell
i'll gift you the damn game
yo yo yo stop okay yeah you already got
me getting this chip
all right you already got me on this
chip
if y'all don't know if y'all didn't see
me put this up
i guess i gotta take this chip i gotta
eat this chip shout out to will me hood
all right i already got a tattoo on my
chest
and now this man got me with this
this right here so listen i'm gonna tell
y'all right now stop
all right stop having me play games i
don't want to play and
i'm checking my dm's and i got a game in
there i don't want to play
i don't like demon souls i'll take it
i'd be able to take it
what else you guys said uh that we have
shown kingdom with the five dollars
with that how great would it be if sony
sent king the now canceled ps5
with the built-in card reader
it was like what the hell are these guys
talking about all right
neil i said did the playstation 5 gonna
come out
with a card right you know when you go
to the store to swipe your card
and yeah you see how to control
then we have jade up as a shill with the
ten dollar ship a chat
man nothing but weirdos messing with
messing with john
uh damn jump me huh it's those dudes in
the basement with dirty ceilings out
all right empty boxes the pizza roll and
unmade beds
df is a solid source
man but yeah we're gonna move on get
this going um
oh yes lord king i'll frame it from um
ps5
dynamic cooling so um yeah it looks like
there was a
obviously the teardown video that went
down i forget the gentleman's name
uh who uh he's one of the sony raps one
of the technological engineer reps
you know um engineer director and uh he
basically i guess you're talking about
how cooling was an important part of
design
for the playstation 5. so um yeah
there's this new interview out they
talked about
three temp additional temperature
sensors that were placed on the
console's main board
allowing sony to optimize fan speed gap
based on gathering temperature data from
gamers and he said in the kings laughing
i don't know
i don't know why it kicks laughing in
the future
various games will appear and apu
behavior data for each game will be
collected
so basically it looks like so a series
of online updates will allow sony to
control the rpm
of the fan and again this is part of
their new cooling system and uh king you
wanted to bring this to the realm
clearly this is your topic i came across
this article
and i said that i was like yo let me do
a little bit more research
so i noticed that they had a whole new
division in their building
and then these dudes sit there and
monitor your playstation
something like you know neil right now
is on level 36 and demon souls
it's getting uh okay his system is
heating up um somebody throttle back his
system
give him more fan power more that's how
this works
and i'm like literally
he said they're gonna monitor your joint
for the fan and they can boost your
joint when it's getting too hot hold on
turn
we need more fan and that's how this
works that's
how
[Laughter]
5 neville's coming out for the
playstation 5 and the uh series x
correct sir
yeah yo gregor can i say that oh greg
can you say that well well
well it says it looks like it on the at
the end of the day it says it on the
trailer you're good
i know i put it there
[Music]
[Laughter]
sir how i assume it will work like what
i think they mean is per game basis so
since it's uh running off of ssd like if
you're running a little indie game
that's not you know
heating up the console then there would
be an update saying hey
run the uh fan at the lowest setting but
if you're running like
you know yeah yeah call of duty or
destiny they like crank that boy up
crank that boy
you can't be doing it just come on be
like
if they were paying people to sit there
and be like just look at numbers being
like hey this game running kind of hot
i will take that job that sounds like
the easiest job
is stupid i'm sorry man i found it so
hilarious
that they even you know talked about
this because i'm pretty sure
that you know xbox is monitored and the
heat's in their system as well
but being that this was an article and
i just made a little scenario in my head
that they had a whole black division
right they had like a whole
a whole team you know do something like
that
black i was gonna get to it yeah okay
listen
they had black suits on and they said
that they black shade like men in black
let me go to your house when your joint
overheat and they couldn't turn it off
and they flash you dude you're
ridiculous
you won't remember this anyway lord son
what was your feelings about this uh let
me get this going these two super chats
yes
we got stitch with the five dollars we
checked king the ps5 no longer has a
card reader
they upgraded to an rfid chip so you can
use apple pay or samsung
you just tap your card on the side of it
is that it savage
then we have a stream kingdom with the 2
super chat saw a job post on sony
looking for fan
controllers
savage yeah there we are spinning flip
with the five dollars if we chat maybe
the ps5 will ship with one of those
nest thermostats oh messy oh messy those
are my people
people wrong yes
we have a jonathan b with the five
dollar super chat i have an idea for the
next patreons here
king does a full play through series of
demon souls on the iop channel
shout out to kids movies i'm playing
jonathan what's up with you people
y'all
i've given all she got captain
mr zulu can we go to warp three
y'all ridiculous anyway let me jump in
on this because this is
super messy um look man at the end of
the day you know
again i'm not familiar i'm not a
hardware developer or whatever
but you know it looks sounds interesting
you know i'm saying some new unique
approach as far as
firmware and variable clocks and stuff
like that look
proof is going to be in the pudding
right once we get these systems in-house
and
the effectiveness and all the stuff
clearly the system is very big and
cooling is a priority with this console
like that is clear
as day you know but look long is it on
overheat
long is for the most part it doesn't
sound like a jet plane when we're
playing those really high intensive
games like you know neil's saying like
you know probably for the indie stuff or
whatever if there's a way to control it
so that
you know it's not really super loud and
it it's effective with the cooling
i think my main thing solved that no
one's talking about is actually
the i think shout out to digital foundry
uh what you call it richard ledbetter
the actual ssd the nvme expansion slot
i'm i want to know if the ssds with um
heatsinks can go in there also the
cooling there because
ssds run hot they've already said that
they
they don't fit in there yep i watched
that one specifically yeah yeah
yeah so so again that's my own i don't
really i don't
i'm not concerned with the calling of
the system i think the how big it is and
the heat sinks and all you see the heat
sink i mean this thing is insane
so it's like they they are designed that
big to be cool even
the contours of the actual the snap-on
stuff all that is designed for airflow
so my thing is though i just want to
know about that ssd
you know for that aspect because again i
know those run hot other than that man
you know
king's gonna have fun with this i
already knew king's gonna have a lot of
fun with this this topic
well i think i i think they'll be fine
because this is ssd they can transfer
data between
your extra one and your current one
right and if they they actively
switching which uh one your game is on
the game you're running
then they don't have to cool the one up
top right so yeah i mean it could be
it could just like they could pull some
slicks it could be lit
and like you said i mean it could be a
situation who knows they would say with
this type of technology the things
they're using
you know you never know what can become
i don't say like industry standard i
mean every console is unique and works
for them
but if it's something that proves to be
very efficient and
revolutionary you may see other people
adopted so we'll see i mean
that's where i'm at with it but uh let
us move on and start
uh the joint before we move on we have a
sparty on with the 20
super chat keep on with the truth iop
love sundays before my beloved lions
lose again
oh detroit in the building
because every time people in detroit get
their hopes up like this is the year
like on thanksgiving on thanksgiving in
detroit
i i just sit there like why are y'all
watching this
and then one year the lions was winning
and then they
they got sweat like they got wiped out i
was like wow
wow you could put me on the field
i i i could i feel that pain as a as a
new york met fan
i understand that pace i'm a jets fan so
you're right yeah jeffy
yeah you kind of write about that but
y'all had the greatest running back in
the history of the game
like literally i would literally y'all
could take that win just give me the
greatest running back
i want my windshield i want my wings i
wasn't even there there was
i was alive i was alive about it what
was me just just that's what that's
your name yeah i'm good if the lion
if you ever win it won't even be
exciting because it'd be like a 20 year
old
graduating from middle school oh my god
that's a lot of pain this is what you
should have been doing
the disrespect
all right let's move on this is your
topic sir what is going on with launches
man
yeah so uh so the xbox series x launches
on november 10th
microsoft has pretty much announced from
all facets of
of the microsoft ecosystem whether it be
overseas or or
here in the states uh that there is
going to be some sort of kind of
launch virtual or launch event um
on the first on the ninth so my question
to you guys is right
what what do you think this sort of
launch event consists of right is it
just sort of like
a kind of like uh like a state of play
type thing well for xbox you know like
they do where
they're they talk about the launch games
and instead the other or
do they use it as an opportunity to show
off that one more thing that we've been
waiting for
thing that since we know we don't have
that big big banger from xbox uh
at the launch of the series x do they
show us what the initiative is working
on do they show us a little bit do they
show us hellblade
in game or something like that to really
get that those last minute you know
you'd be surprised how often one game
convinces the person to go
buy a console right um do you think we
get some sort of reveal like that on the
9th
that's meant to sort of push people kind
of over the edge and have them stand
outside in front of the store the next
day to try to get a couple
friends let's get a little nail in there
man this worldwide launch that's being
hinted what do you feel do you think
xbox has any more surprises up their
sleeves
uh i don't think so
[Music]
there was actually a lot of talk about
how um on
day one they're not saying it but day
one they have a decent allotment
for people going in to buy um i don't
know
i don't know numbers but they we've kind
of heard from people that are
in retail saying that yeah we have
allotment it may not be a lot
but if you're out there early you may be
able to get one if you haven't
pre-ordered
which i did not expect at all for this
this sort of yeah
dangerous to me it kind of does sound
dangerous i don't want to be standing
online anywhere
um not what i want to be doing
mm-hmm no okay what's up
yeah so i'll be just dealing so pretty
much you're just like you know you're
not really anticipating anything
crazy yeah i hope they get i mean they
don't really need anything everybody's
like kind of in their camps they got
their pre-orders in if they want to
export
they want xbox i don't think there's
anything else they really need to do
right lord king what are you
anticipating did xbox buy new zealand
what are you thinking man oh no that was
um a flight uh fight simulator that was
showing you
new zealand um in that altitude and all
that stuff
um also um
how can i how can i put it without out
in somebody oh
okay remember when phil had on that
shirt uh
and they said everybody's wondering uh
how him and gabe was doing
oh exclusive so
i may be wrong i may be right um i think
it has something to do with that
uh because again gabe actually did
something in new zealand
so i think it has something to do with
that and the fact that it's going to
launch in new zealand first
uh because of the time difference right
i believe um
they're gonna have like a big party and
the reason why they didn't do
the second round because everybody's
like oh playstation has more you know um
the reason why they didn't do second
round of pre-orders
uh was to have them available at store
right so
when you go in of you know day of
because a lot of people
felt that they didn't get a chance or it
wasn't fair
uh for them to get a pre-order and stuff
like that so it takes away from the
experience of actually going in the
store day one you know that
that that that line i know during these
times right now
it's a little bit harder as well you
know to be standing out online because
we was not doing any social distancing
at
all when when we was there you know
getting our pre-orders going
and i'm thinking back and i'm like man i
could have just been cold up
like the whole situation i had no mask
on i'm
about to fight it dude it's kind of
crazy but um
uh they're gonna have something day one
when you go to the stores to pick them
up i believe playstation is gonna have
some
as well hopefully you know when it comes
to that hopefully you know that's the
situation
and they're trying to get back to that
you know point of purchase walking in
uh i believe uh gamestops plays a big
role in that and that deal with the
partnership that they have with them
i think more systems will be available
at gamestop as opposed to
best buys or pc riches or wherever else
uh
you know electronics or walmart but i
think gamestop will be
a lot of guys uh first choice they
should be their first choice being
the deal that they did make with uh
gamestop and i
think gamestop will make sure that they
service as much people as they possibly
can so
it sounds like good stuff i think
they're gonna have something like for
that last thing they're gonna show a
trailer probably
right for that uh for one of their games
because everybody's been asking for the
initiative game so
they probably show a trailer for that or
something yeah i mean it's interesting
you know obviously we saw the tweets
from the um xbox new zealand account
i believe obviously with the time
difference they'll be ahead so
you know maybe they'll have something
you know the vibe i'm getting i don't
know so i'm getting more of like a fan
fest celeb celebratory vibe
you know i mean yeah y'all do this fan
fest uh that's a disaster
i didn't make it on time but i heard it
was it was a disaster
people travis scott is going to come out
on stage right
he's going to come out with the
controller
he's going to blow into the controller
you're gonna turn into a flute
i'm done we're gonna walk out of the
series next fridge before the friday
gonna bust
off do you see the the stuff that i
gotta deal with yeah
gotta walk out
microsoft uh like if they don't do
something like this they probably
brought another studio
that that's that's the whole right so we
see we see
um obviously the new zealand we see xbox
mexico put a tweet out
you know obviously we did hear rumors
that you know i don't know how true they
are but like oh
the bethesda acquisition you know the
center max acquisition is not the only
acquisition and they have something else
cooking
who knows i mean i will say this though
i thought
the zenimax acquisition revealing that
information the day before the
pre-orders went on sale was huge
i think that created a big uh hype and
gave the base hope and
i think there were more people online
than the hardcore xbox community thought
they would be
when they went to uh to go to go
pre-order it so i mean we'll see you
know i
love it to be a studio acquisition at
the end of the day you know
just generating any type of buzz for the
console i think it's cool so let's just
see i don't know what's going on but it
definitely seemed like this
is a little steamy in here oh oh here we
go
here we go you dropping that nba
exclusive you driving that exclusive
what up gabe listen
i was saying i don't know why like the
internet is cool
uh with like microsoft buying like
cinemax but they're not cool with
console exclusives for one game
you know what's funny it's an
interesting thing i think that um
some some people you know with
exclusives
it's very important right and and for
whatever reason there seems to be a
disparity of
who it's okay for and who is not okay
for
yeah and at the end of the day look we
come from that era
if look if a game is only over there or
something
guess what we're gonna have to get it if
we like that game so i'm not limiting
myself
because you don't say i'm not complying
like oh wise they don't look there's
some things that i feel are extreme
but at the end of the day you know when
destiny or when um street fighter was
over there or a place
you know final fantasy 7 is over there
on playstation i gotta get a playstation
that's that's just what it is you know
what i'm saying
we're buying spiderman right but that's
the games
you know i have my xbox so i'm good i'm
i'm not in this situation i think the
problem is
a lot of the fanboys limit themselves
and they
instead of being a gamer right you lock
yourself into the one ecosystem
and yeah you you get upset why are you
pocket watching
that's what they can afford that's what
i was gonna say i actually agree with
that because like they forget where the
concept awards started where you could
only afford
one console like that was your team
right now
i get that i get that but
listen i get that but back in the day i
think it was different because it was
more like all right
i'm gonna go over my friend house and
i'm gonna go see that say or i'm gonna
go see that whatever
and i just feel it was different now
just like like yo
like if it's over there like i gotta be
mad that it's over there like
just go get
i can see that argument for younger
people right that's right
a lot of the people that talking smack
on the internet
i don't respect you 40 years old
playstation
to me is one of those things where it's
like when
you talk about the single game going
over it and i think it's just
it's certain sections of the internet
and feel that's a petty move
like oh i'm gonna i'm i'm gonna pay for
this exclusivity for six months i'm
gonna pay for it for a year right
um but if you go out go out right and
buy them
you could be mad but at the end of the
day they bought them they're
always going to be moved over to that
other platform at some point you're
going to have to either
deal with it suck it up and deal with it
right or just be mad continue to be mad
at that it got moved from the plaza
and i get that not everybody does have
the money to get everything i get that
right you everyone makes an informed
decision on what they think their
platform or their preference or what
they think they're gonna like
you know but there's gonna be situations
where your team didn't make this
acquisition
you know saying that you wasn't excited
about so what are you then gonna do
right are you gonna continue to be mad
and be
angry and throw rocks at the screen that
you you know they didn't sign this game
like at some point
it's either you deal with it you know
what i'm saying or if you're
able you save and you try to figure out
a way to get it you're saying but
i just feel this whole thing about being
mad because it's not
on your platform or whatever to me it
doesn't serve any any purpose
it's done what's done is done like
you're gonna have to make a decision
either way so
that's just how i look at it i think it
comes out of ignorance as well because
it's like
we literally do the same thing for
netflix and amazon and hulu
where like they don't make these movies
for a certain platform most of the time
the platforms like buy them um and like
you're uh
to be honest with uh like you know just
gamers in general
um there needs to be more understanding
of how like these things work and these
deals are made because like a certain
game
um uh there has to be deals made to make
that money back because
um like say you make a game right and
then uh
sony says hey we'll pay for your entire
development so you are already free and
clear
right if you give us facts if you give
you if
you give us exclusive yeah for a year so
so you you're saying like you're gonna
stop for them from keep the lights on in
their house
so they can have it they can just have
straight up profit after that
like i'm like yo like
[Music]
that's a deal that no one can say no to
bro it's the same argument we had when
we had developers with iop
and they were telling us how the
structure of game pass was working for
them
and they were literally saying you know
i'm saying like look you know
we're getting that money they but like
basically xbox gave them an
uh an estimate of what their projection
would be
right so it's like they're getting that
up front and it's such a
financial ease right for these guys to
say okay now i could breathe easily we
ain't got a rush we got to worry about
when it's coming in so it's like for us
to tell the developer who needs to keep
the lights on
yo you ain't you can't you don't need to
take that bag because
you know i need this on everything like
come on we got to be realistic
it's still a business it's still making
money here that's the thing we got to
think about that's all i'm saying we
don't we don't do that nobody else we
don't do that to like rappers we don't
do that to like movie makers
but like for some reason devs they can't
we can't make money yeah you can't make
money now man i'm mad
it shouldn't you you shouldn't be
putting it on that platform if you don't
mind
yeah gamers are fickle and they're petty
man
when xbox signed that that deal for
right i always come back to this one
rise of the tomb raider
they started for a year and and you go
they signed it for a year and then
the vibe when the year was up and it was
going to playstation
the bible was like f that game yeah yeah
that's stupid generally i heard a lot of
that i'm like are you kidding me
are you serious that you're not gonna
play this game because you didn't get it
a year ago
right um i did i didn't really want you
didn't really want it then because you
could have just went out and brought a
200
xbox and just just play the game
you know there's no barrier like i i
don't i don't get the whole mentality to
it because
these dudes really think i think they
really think i'm not buying like a
playstation like i haven't had
playstation my whole life like i haven't
been sleeping in front of stores before
the playstation came
out i'm that dude all right so just
because i say oh xbox x y and z so what
who cares it's actually fun smoke
that's exactly what at the end of the
day look we you joke
right we know you have a preference
right but at the end of the day
you don't limit yourself from not
picking up a playstation 5.
you don't limit yourself say yo i'm not
going to get miles morales yeah
tony this and pony that right
they don't remember the month that he
was talking about spider-man
every single way i'm gonna be doing that
they don't remember
they don't remember when we were sitting
there talking about game of the year
stuff and king is like i don't care what
y'all said
last of us two is it and this is why and
this is the
and he went i can't wait till we get to
our ratings at the end
they're gonna hate me again because i
don't care what comes out from now until
the
last of us two is definitely gonna be
because ain't no game made me
cry and scared to pick a controller i
paused the game so much
because i didn't want to do a certain
thing yeah you know those are for the
the people that still haven't played the
game
and i've never felt that level of
emotion
for a game i've played the first one i
had emotion in that first one too
but that second one it ripped my heart
out and threw it on the table
and i was like man hey and i know
exactly the moment you're talking about
that happened to me too because when i
threw that rope over that fence
i felt it
you are ridiculous he's ridiculous i
love his messages
it made me feel so dumb i was like this
is
real life
i disagree with this statement king i
think the patriarchs have caused you
more pain than the last of us
[Laughter]
ps5 dynamic cooling just like their
dynamic 4k
ps4 pro lol
april cooling for the win fast has a
regular fan so 1990s
hey yo peter shut up
[Laughter]
one p oh what peter said what do you say
peter uh
four two four twenty he because he
talked crazy sometimes he took craig
welcome to the realm lord bobby moulas
oh
any thoughts on why you can link steam
and xbox accounts hmm
surprise hey gabe how you doing oh my
god
are you implying a potential i'm not
implying anything you're getting looking
for me
and uh xbox on to the next one
who do we have yeah
it's content exclusive on third-party
games yeah this is okay
this is a problem this is what feels
really petty right
and i think people get get over the fact
that the game is exclusive at some point
the the content stuff in yeah if you put
a gun in my head yeah i prefer to the
game be exclusive than the content of a
third party yeah
i had to live with that definitely y'all
none for a whole year or y'all had a
nightfall or something for a whole year
yo that yo
but to neal's point dudes took the bag
it depends on how many zeros like we
knew how many zeros we would understand
no no you know what i totally understand
it from that point the only reason why i
didn't do it with destiny because it
doesn't mean it's like a college course
and you i did i was not going to go
start all over again over there
i was before right now with this pc
stuff this dude over here
this dude is a pc dude right there right
here he packs up his bags
and he went over the pc and started all
over again all his rage
all this stuff i don't hear nothing he's
talking about i'm not doing it bro i
feel it i'm feeling but that's 60 frames
that wow wow i was like okay this is
what this is
you'll be back i don't care
i'll be back december 8th y'all december
8th for that field of view sliders
ps5 fight games and excuses everything
else i like that yeah
don't don't limit yourself brother don't
let me exactly get everything
king david the guy ain't playing god
with the five dollar super chat if
microsoft doesn't buy xenomax google
amazon would have
cinematic wanted to be bought sony
already has two exclusive zenimax mad
love for the show thank you so yeah
that's something
really i'm gonna be honest with y'all
man i i i love the competition in the
gaming space
that said i do not agree with
the position at least at this point that
amazon is taking
and that google is taken with this this
is our platform right
and as powerful as those companies are
as much money as those companies are
i would much prefer that one of the big
three buy these companies
and it stays within those three right
then these two other ones
you kind of usurpers come in and try to
take those companies right what's the
use
no i honestly i you know and that's it
sounds
bad to say that but i just don't think
at this point in time looking at
streaming as the thing
right is the right thing to do so for me
losing
losing a company like zenimax and all of
those properties to
an amazon
you'd rather be with the people who have
a little bit more experience and
commitment to gaming
from a corporation standpoint exactly as
opposed to somebody new
that's a bigger corporate entity but
it's just doing it for a streaming
purpose kind of thing
absolutely i gotta get what you're doing
and we got a pixel bit g right
um super chat cough cough
cyberpunk hold my beard okay i'll get
looks i'm [ __ ] coming bro
i'm gonna be honest though like until it
shows me
hey 80s is my game of the year right now
which one
hades is my game wow okay i hate this
fight though i already
heard good stuff then we got what we got
we got uh
kingdom gossip at the vga is phil gonna
say we bought gay
you're gonna bring out games
that'd be crazy that'd be crazy that's
crazy
um we have gamer by choice with the
twenty dollars we chat great show and
thank you for having a passionate dev of
color on to discuss his love of gaming
luke lords and neal absolutely yeah
we're going to definitely run that trail
don't worry i'm going to run that
trailer back
right in too so for the people who
missed it because i know a couple y'all
missed it but yeah continue we got
everybody caught up
uh yeah we're good all right cool cool
man so yeah that was pretty much
it as far as that is concerned let's get
into the poll and get out of here
with both next-gen consoles steadily
approaching and now in the hands of the
media
what specific technical aspect of
next-gen consoles has you the most
quotations
what is it that's the end quote oh that
the media has it oh my god you're still
riding
you're still running what technical
specific technical aspects of next gen
console consoles has you most excited
the choices are a
cpu and gpu raw power of both consoles
b nvme six ssd load times for quicker
gameplay
c 60 frames per second performance mode
and pushing up to 120 or d
i don't care too many people excited for
paid remasters and back compat launch
games
shout out to all those in the chat those
will be the voices those will go
up later on i want to salute lord neal
but before we salute them to everybody
who missed the trailer we're going to
run it back right now then we're going
to give up a proper
outro so if again check out my man and
get that beat rocket
turn up your radio turn it off
it's coming
i keep it going i keep it moving like
i keep it going like
[Music]
ain't never seen anything quite like
this in a league of my own i'm one of a
kind i'll be in the zone i'll be on the
grind i'll leave me alone you're wasting
my time the clock sticking i'm not
slipping i gotta get it
every second every minute
[Music]
and i'm on the right track
[Music]
that's what's up man yo shout out again
lloyd neal in the rum and he's got
an amazing trolls of osiris that's the
story he has to tell us before he gets
about oh yeah
man come on so like that's that's why
when i was like oh i'm going to be on
that podcast
because like i was destiny day one like
i played on my 360 and switched over
uh and had to run that whole demo back
destiny was nothing but that beta
we waited for like trousers osiris to
drop right
so we kept like uh hopping out and
hopping back oh by the way
they give you
i just wanted to let you why you tell
your destiny i appreciate y'all
um but yeah yeah we uh we we hopped into
uh trials of
as soon as it like dropped you know back
in the day back in my day
um and me and me and my fire team we got
we ran
clean sweet flawless the
like fall flawless victory the last game
like uh
we played some real players i guess
they almost swept us it was like one
note left and then my my boy
like he he got pissed and he turned off
his headset
and like i was like oh god and then he
murdered the
hole he looked down
man he swept them so bad when he get mad
he just like run through people that's
what's up
and then and then we uh you know we went
and got the chest and got all the gear
or whatever
and i'm checking online to see who else
did it and no one else did it for like a
good hour i just didn't have it nobody
and i was like they they're not tracking
it
it was literally the first guys that
beat trousers we were the first ones
what this is on ps4 ps4 yeah it's on ps4
man i hope somebody got that data they
can prove me right because i i'm sitting
over here telling this story all the
time with no proof
oh yo let me reach out to bungie man i
might have to reach out to but we need
we need them trials oversized
reparations
look at the top three i'm in there
and i did the same we did the same thing
with the other version you know
uh trousers yeah trousers
like
[Laughter]
salute to you number one again ariel
knights
never yield neil jones where can the
fine people find you
and give us some more information about
this game release
platforms you know shoot your shot man
yeah yeah so uh like if you like the
game if you like the music specifically
just uh come to my twitter page if you
come to my twitter page you know i post
everything and everything like if you
like
twitter what's that twitter brother uh
at uh aerial underscore night just like
is this my name you can copy and paste
the name from the title of this video
put it into google i'm the first one to
pop up uh so just follow me if you got
any questions for me just hit me up i
try to get back to everybody but uh we
come into the playstation
uh four and five xbox you know all
the acronyms of that um
hopefully switch games hopefully
hopefully switch game coming in hot
i'm working on
i'm putting pressure on nintendo today
nintendo what's up
my man's out here man this be perfect
platform wanna go with the beast with
the running let's get it
yeah and if if you're in detroit i'm
easy to find you know in the before
times i used to go to all the you know
detroit events
so you know you'll be able to find me
hit me up go down brother yo good to see
your journey an absolute pleasure to
have you amazing guests
about the smoke having fun man we
definitely got to bring it back
you know as you get closer to release
man but keep up your journey brother
love what you're doing man tremendous
tremendous story tremendous
appreciation i know you already know
lloyd
where can i find people find you what
you got going on sir yeah no doubt man
thank you to neil for coming through um
you know what's funny like
we we sit here and we i saw somebody
saying we're almost 5 000 uh subscribers
and that's kind of bonkers to me right
and when you start seeing your platform
and
kind of grow in that way you realize
that you have a duty to do certain
things
um that you don't necessarily think
about in the beginning
i remember when my first trip to pax
right
and i'm like you know i'm running around
with king interviewing people and
it's in it you know you're kind of
wide-eyed at everything because
you're engaging in this thing that
you've never done before
and and you're talking to all these
different devs and you kind of like star
struck a little bit right
and then we're about to go to lunch and
king sees
some developers in a corner by by the
escalator
uh african-america african-american
developers and he's like
before we go i just want to let you know
that we're coming right back to
interview you guys
i'm gonna make sure we interview you
guys and you know
in that moment you realize wait a minute
we have
if we're creating this platform we have
to make sure that
part of that is to
give a voice to voices that aren't being
heard elsewhere
um and when we did that with the swim
sanity
developers right and right there
everything clicked for me it's like okay
this is what we are right this is an
absolute part of what we are and
to see and and it's in a way it's a sad
thing right because it shouldn't have to
be that way
it should be that you have your place in
the industry with everyone else and
there is no there's no dividing line but
unfortunately that's not the world that
we live in
so uh it gave it gives me so much
pleasure to have you on here and to
to know your story and to be able to
have a platform where people hear your
story
and hear about your game and are excited
about your game
um because we
it this is something that we have to do
this is something we have to do
absolutely 100
and and for somebody like you who's
worked so hard and it's come to the
point where it's like you know what
if you're not making that space for me
i'm gonna make my i love that
yeah that was the part i like congrats
to
neil for your journey everything that
you've done man uh with you nothing but
the best
all the success and you know the lords
are gonna be behind you 100
when launch comes we're gonna be right
there
100 so uh congratulations to you man
yeah thank you thank you so much man
absolutely lord king what's going on sir
i love the fact that he was down for the
messi
i actually actually love it i i love
your attitude
i love that you said yo this was going
to be my last game
and you was like yeah i'm just going to
go for i'm just going to swing i'm just
going to get up there and i'm just going
to hit a home run i'm just going to
i'm going to swing this back come hella
high water and it's going to be what
it's going to be
and you just freed yourself and it just
i see the translation
into the game the game looks free like
he
like he's unbridled and then the music
is free-flowing it's
i'm telling you like
when you reach that point where you stop
caring
not but like you said i don't care for
everybody to love it i'm making it for
a certain amount of group that me a lot
of that those people that have my taste
this is me i'm if if i'm gonna leave a
mark
this is the mark i'm gonna leave and
you have your references you made sure
that your name is dead
you know like like it's it's just those
little things
you stay true to you like whatever stuff
that you were doing before
that you was trying to fit it to fit
whatever that mold was
this is you do you see how
fire you are like the chat is like
yeah ain't ain't even this dude is dope
as hell
so that's that's and i love i love
when we get days like this yes where we
could see
real original and i'm not just gonna
like you know like go over the fact that
you're black i know
that you black it was harder you know i
know that
because i i grow up with that it's
harder for us
right but i also love the fact that
dude you doing your thing no matter what
color you are
you doing your damn thing and i know
from this point it's just going to be
that much higher
right because you found yourself saying
to hell with it
it's beautiful so i salute for you being
here today uh i
i can't wait to get this game because
i'm definitely going to buy it
no bro because at the end of the day
like like i've said the best kicks at
best like
you know we just don't see a lot of it
right so it's our duty to support it and
like i said what you told gregor
you know what i'm saying shout out to
head up and them guys like what you know
as far as when you made your trailer
whenever like you know you wanted
you know an african-american or a outlet
of color
to present the game you know not that
you're restricting any other outlets but
you wanted you made that
clear that resonated you know i'm saying
that definitely resonated shout out to
gregor he's saying it comes out to all
platforms i'm gonna hold you to that
um
that really means a lot so to like solve
said is is our duty like with king
you know what i'm saying and we're at
the shows you know what i'm saying again
we don't see
a lot of developers that look like us so
it's so cool to see and again hearing
your story hearing your journey
you know i'm saying all the nuances of
this game that make it you and like you
said this might not be for everybody but
it's
you it's all you and what you are going
to do and you like
if they don't like it that's all numb
and so far so good we're definitely well
received we're definitely feeling the
vibes feeling the energy
and we can't wait man we pulling for you
brother we pulling for you man man y'all
so awesome
thank you brother appreciate you man
appreciate you so that i gotta i gotta
come
uh back on something oh you already know
oh yeah king straight whenever he starts
kicked out you gotta bring it up
it's a thing going around with the
playstation you got blowing the
controller the controllers are gonna
blow back
at you the system's gonna blow at you
you got people
in remote play i'm just saying if like
something like the playstation and some
people's girlfriend like
[Laughter]
yo they want to know if they're able to
pre-order the game they're able to
pre-order
uh and then soon you know the
playstation stuff gets settled then
you know you'll be able to pre-order on
there too yeah xbox game pass stuff he
ain't saying that paul but i'm over here
if it's gonna be the reason why i buy a
digital game on my playstation it's fine
okay
yo but i'm gonna tell you right now when
microsoft when phil dominance maximus
are really
[Laughter]
as soon as i figure out all this stuff
and you know it's updated and everything
i post everything on twitter please come
follow me on twitter yes because
all right i don't really care about the
clout and stuff like that
but you know twitter numbers get you in
the room all right so let's hear that
let's do that right now i already
followed you right
now but we got to do it for the chat you
know what i'm saying here listen man
i'm gonna drop it right now please
support the brother right now again
the aerial night is twitter get him
at the table get him a seat at that
table let it be a game pass exclusive
playstation fans support it man it's
coming to ps5 coming to all the major
platforms and
hopefully hopefully switch again but
look that's what we got man look
everybody enjoy your sunday
hilarious fun show so if you got
anything with super chat yeah
guys as i said earlier next week is
d-day next week's show will be a big one
ladies and gentlemen we will be
announcing the winners of the series x
and the ps4 the halloween show exactly
so if you have not joined the realm yet
be sure you do that
because by saturday evening that will be
the cut off time
yes new kos going up on monday yes sir
and on friday definitely the new kos
is going to be up it's halloween theme
so
i don't know it might be a little hot
situation he said we missed super chats
oh yeah it's bitcoin yeah we got a
couple yeah yeah we did we did we bought
it we got to get those we got to do this
right
we're gonna do this right now oh sorry
big cloud yes another fire show guys
salute
uh that's from big cloud stitch with the
five thousand which i had a new patreon
tier king play scoring on stream
yo that game looked good for me oh no
let me get one bad mother man he's
surprised we don't like the dizz pistol
order dripping no thank you
great to see detroit representation keep
persevering neal
you have talent thank you ilp for
keeping sundays entertaining
when my lions came yo yo savage savage
let's go get forte with the five dollar
super chat that's what i'm talking about
no loser shooter can compare to the go
i wonder where my destiny hater is at
call cough my co-host shout out to dps
podcast shout out to
slow mo backlash big slanderous oh we
didn't get diggle not joined the realm
yeah yeah yeah yeah no we didn't ding
dingle nuts
that's out of control but god bless
one last thing from our generous donor
uh lord um
uh kidswill 26. um it was not two months
of game pass
it's three months of game pass ultimate
he will be donating to the winner of the
xbox series x
yeah he hit me in um on twitter all
right so we're getting about here it's
probably gonna be the last week you get
soft's tinder information we're gonna
put it out now for the promo
everybody enjoy your sunday attic will
be back you work double shipping oh sin
vendetta thank you brother follow super
chat
king why did you kill mario he's he's
going to say he's uh
looking at you right now
you know that note joined the realm here
and we ought to hear
peace hi this is lord sovereign from the
iron lord podcast
as you guys may recall a few months back
king david otw announced an amazing
giveaway for the xbox series x
well i'm proud to announce that the iron
lords podcast will once again be giving
away another console
at the end of this year and that console
will be a playstation
5. you heard correctly so
how do you get in on this amazing
giveaway let me explain
if you're already a member of the realm
you're good to go if you support us
either on patreon
or youtube you already have a ballot to
win this
amazing console and if you support us on
both platforms
you have two ballots to win this amazing
console as you also have two ballots to
win an xbox series x
so if you're not a member of the realm
what are you waiting for head on over to
patreon.com
go to the ironlord's podcast patreon
page become a member of the realm
to get your chance to win a playstation
5.
you can also join us on youtube iron
lord podcast
become a member of the realm and you
will also have a ballot to win
a playstation 5 console and if you want
to support us
on both platforms you'll have two
ballots for
each system to win either a playstation
5 console
or of course as king david said and xbox
series
x this is an amazing opportunity
that the iron lords podcast are so happy
to bring to our community because you
guys give so much back to us
so again if you're not a member of the
realm yet what are you waiting for
go out join the realm on either patreon
or youtube and until next time i'll see
you at the round table